[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
the fire is strong
but i don't care
what i ever want to be
[Music]
for is eyes
think about it later
think about it later
[Music]
all i ever wanna be is
[Music]
feel it
[Music]
think about it later
[Music]
is
[Music]
as the world entered an unprecedented
crisis magnus carlson and chess 24
acted quickly to create the first online
chess tour of his kind
working 24 7 we brought together the
best players in the world
for the largest online prize fund ever
we have
an opportunity to play on online
tournaments
and while other
sportsmen are basically doing nothing
chess players can can play the
tournaments and as a chess player as a
top player
i need to be able to compete against
strong players regularly
otherwise i'd lose my friend and get
rossy
so in this regard i'm very grateful to
have high level
competitions and it's not
sometimes it's not even about the money
but sometimes it's about
the way the players are treated and the
opportunity
to be able to play against the strong
and top
grandmasters regularly in a serious
event
and so in that regard i'm i'm very happy
that this is happening
broadcast live in 10 languages the tour
innovated
and filled the void created by the lack
of in-person play
reaching more people than any online
chess event ever
good luck to chess 24 and you're
on a right way to organize such a great
tournament
there was fun and laughter oh my gosh
what a gorgeous square queen e5 is
to my mind this queen on e5 is like a
goddess
it's perfect as you as you're showing
it's a it's an absolute pin on the rook
there's a pin on the queen
uh talk about you know dark square
domination against the bishop on b1
which is a light square
piece this is the this is a dream move
there was tension and controversy what a
game
whoa and magnus gave up his bishop
with the move rook a a peter
yeah this is this is a already something
i mean an indication that something went
wrong yeah for magnusi
he miscalculated he maybe maybe not
miscalculated he just blundered this
bishop takes a
five idea you know you you put the
bishop on a square
uh but hang on night for queen a8
queen a8 that's a turnaround move
oh my goodness queen a8 rook a1
queen h1 mate peter
ding blundered terribly there were
instructive learning moments
we have discovered uh e6 was a very
strong move for neapolis she
opens up the diagonal of the queen and
at the same time
shots out the d5 bishop from the defense
black has to play rookie seven to
protect the popcorn and the seventh rank
but now
the queen comes from the f5 queen f2
threatening rookhouse 7
and its curtains so the position is
collapsing
right now here black has to resign
and there was lots of great chairs
wow wow it's really uh an incredible
game like showing how
a completely lost position can gradually
turn
into a winning position if you just
trade all the right pieces it's really
this game is really a masterpass on
on the trades what he should be trading
and what not and when i said that
trading the queens and the bishops uh is
good for black i never imagined it
ever happened because it's just it was
so far away from them wow
and it's suspicious
i find the games very exciting actually
the knockout stage is
very exciting four unique online events
and a grand final made up the magnus
carlson chess tour
and the world took notice
[Music]
the magnus carlsen chess tour has been
the most watched online chess event
in history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments
as the first season approaches its
conclusion we want your help to do
something even bigger
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help underserved
communities
kiva does incredible work providing
micro loans to help people around the
world
create opportunity for themselves and
their communities when the pandemic
started
kiva set up a global covet 19 response
fund to help small businesses get back
on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world
chess has helped me a lot it's my job
career and it also makes me who i
am now in this difficult period
the magnus carlsen chester has provided
me
with opportunities to play and compete
and it also brings company and joy to
the chess fans
in addition i joined the
kiva campaign in order to
helping help to help companies
affected by the epidemic chess24 wants
to help make that happen
during the tours final we will be
donating 50
of all proceeds from new premium
memberships to kiva
go premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools
in cities and countries of your choice
in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
[Music]
together
hello everybody and welcome to the
magnus carlson chess
store benefiting kiva finals
i am absolutely thrilled to be here for
what could potentially be
the very last day of the magnus carlson
chess store
as hikaru nakamura the five times u.s
champion
is one set victory away from writing
history
he if he wins today he wins
the final which basically means that
magnus carlsen
has to win on demand to take the finals
to its final and seventh
set it's been an absolutely incredible
ride
so far and such a treat for all of us
to watch and to experience and to
witness this world-class
chess uh with both these gladiators uh
fighting it out back and forth
i think when i think when we had this
final set up between hikaru and magnus
clearly the two best performers
off the tour we all knew that we were in
for a fight
but this is not even a fight this is not
even a war
this is an all-out battle between uh
between these two punching blows after
blows
getting back up going back down again
it's
been just absolutely sensational from
the very start
from day one we've been treated to
explosive chess
and set five was no different
hikaru nakamura of course as we said
needs one more set to clinch the entire
finals yesterday's set was super
exciting i mean the first four rapid
games completely did not it was a slow
start it didn't set us up for what was
upcoming
uh but that was just the calm before the
storm because
nothing could have prepared us for the
madness that we witnessed
in the blitz and the armageddon section
check out all the big moments from
yesterday's set
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the protection around white's king is
bare
yeah absolutely i mean okay
what kind of winning chances are we
talking about from the right side and
what is done on the clock
no increment there a terrible situation
to win
simply a perfectly played armageddon
game by the blacks
side in the in in my view
[Music]
a go big or go home day for the world
champion as he must win on demand to
keep the
match going hikaru nakamura a one set
victory away
from clinching the finals i think uh the
five times u.s champion has done what
few thought would be possible when we
got into this final he's taken the lead
thrice from magnus carlsen in his sets
in the entire match and now with
absolutely no margin for error
it is uh it's now or game over
for magnus carlsen and of course the the
two
players are going to be playing four
rapid games
if it's with a time control 15 minutes
plus 10 seconds if that's a tie and we
see a 2-2 score they move on to the
blitz
which is a five minute with a three
second
increment and if that's a tie with a one
one score
we move on to the armageddon which sees
white with an extra minute but in a
must-win situation if it's a draw
then black wins the set uh step 5 was
the first set where we actually
witnessed an armageddon and
and absolutely flawlessly played by
hikaru we were discussing whether magnus
should take the white pieces or the
black pieces magnus in any case
always picks the color for the
armageddon uh
just a brilliant set and completely
i think today is uh going to be an
all-out day from the world champion
because
there is so much at stake a big
paycheck ahead the winner of the tour
goes back
with a hundred and forty thousand dollar
while the runner-up
gets eighty thousand dollars um
[Music]
daniel dubob and dinglarin
went back with forty thousand dollars i
feel like that that was another lifetime
ago like this
match has just taken up uh just taken up
all our attention and all our energy and
it i think a few of you also wrote to us
that how and this is something that
hikaru also spoke about that how it
feels uh
very like a casper of karpov match up
but a lot more exciting a lot more
faster not that five month
48 game situation which is everyday
high adrenaline action i think what's
been amazing is these two players when
we see them it's not even over-the-board
chess but when we see them on the webcam
when we see their faces their body
language it's clear that they're
giving every single bit of themselves
to the to every single game that they
are playing and of course a big day for
the world champion he's got to make some
big decisions
uh the berlin hasn't been working out
great for him
and uh the big question is what is he
going to show on the board today because
he's
got to catch hikaru up maybe it's time
that he took some advice uh
from anish giri as aneesh has a hot
knowledge a bomb dropped on chesible
he suggests the french as he makes the
french great again have a look
[Music]
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course makes it great because
like
it's a opening but with i've done so
much work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like basically correct also like fun i
mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
so if you've had enough of the berlin
action then definitely check out
anisha's course on the french and
there's a great inaugural deal on it
with a 40
off on a lifetime repertoire by one of
the best players in the world uh i think
it's uh
incredible and this is something that
yes peter and i have been speaking about
on the broadcast just what uh
what a an unthinkable time this
is when we can get insights and tips and
uh opening files from the very best in
the world and it's just
a click away i mean this is sometimes we
just got to pinch ourselves for all the
action that we are
we are being treated to and of course
the other big action is
always happening with with you guys and
a big shout out to all of you for
engaging with us throughout the tour uh
to our audience watching us on different
platforms we hit
big numbers during this final and of
course everything that just 24
and the tour aims to do is is because of
you
and all the encouragement and the
feedback and your involvement in the
tour is
it has been has been just phenomenal
uh let's take a look at what you guys
had to say about the incredible set five
that we had
leon watson still buzzing after
yesterday's day of chess the tour final
is more like a basketball match
uh bulls versus 98 or jordan west is
having
um carson and nakamura going toe to toe
with each other is amazing to watch i
think even in basketball they've got
this
best of seven series uh that happened so
it's a bit of a reflection on
on how we've also seen nba uh formats
and i think what i think the big part
is that a lot of us have always felt
that
especially in a long match format magnus
is just unstoppable i mean
who does anyone even come close how can
you even beat him
and hikaru nakamura so far has done it
thrice
in this final let's move on history in
the making perhaps we'll find out today
edward writing in with after living
inside hikaru's head since forever the
tables may finally have turned for mc
uh naka is definitely playing more
freely and winning when he needs to is
today the day to crown
a new king of the lockdown the big
question what's going to happen today
because hikaru nakamura is
one set victory away from writing
history
and this is such an uh such a insightful
comment because
we've seen it in the past these two
whenever they've met
it almost feels like in chess language
like you say you know
a client and hikaru has always been
something like that for magnus
magnus has a tremendous score against
hikaru in over the broadcast in online
chats rapid and blitz
we've seen him over and over win and
hikaru himself has spoken about this
that how
there you know it's you always have this
one opponent you have difficulty
playing against but something's changed
in this final and it's always been
hikaru who's taken the lead in the match
and magnus playing catch up
uh i think one of the big one of the big
reasons for that
has been just incredible defensive
technique that
hikaru has shown over the board in very
difficult positions
and that's a task not i i wouldn't even
say not many
i can't think of anyone who's up for
with
when magnus gets a better position the
kind of pressure he puts on your
on the opponent moves by move whether
it's tactical or strategic just
constantly the
the the most difficult questions to
answer over the board
hikaru's been up for that task and i
think that has been one of the more
defining
uh uh defining characteristics in
hikaru's plate that
that's led us to this point let's move
on we also had ashley riding in with are
we ready for the magnus fight back
yes we are ready for that and i think we
also know of course hikaru has
been tremendous but if there is one
player in the world who we know when
he's up against the wall just
just his capacity and his capability of
making a comeback
of his ability to win on demand just
unmatched is the world champion magnus
carlsen
and of course uh we as commentators can
only hope and can only want
the very best chess to come on the board
and may the best player win
naka to win it ashley supports nakang
not because i prefer him but simply
because carlson wins everything usually
the big winner here is just actually 100
agree with that i think we've often had
this narrative of magnus winning
everything and tournaments have started
feeling like a race for second place for
all these other guys but let's see what
happens today
and we had chess
master with impact it's thriller drama
strong chess and emotions every day
let's see what he sent
us so and indeed yes we've seen it's
i think with online chess the one thing
which is super exciting for us as fans
to watch has just been this
uninhibited uh
expressions and feelings of players
which you don't get to see so often in
over the board chess because they're a
lot more guarded but in this setup when
you know you're playing on a zoom call
and you've got one camera in front of
you and you've got these
two three cameras around you but there's
absolutely no human presence
you often forget that people are
watching you and we've seen these
amazing
uh emotions being displayed and just
how hard chess can be chia mekaru is on
fire and playing unbelievable chess
kudos to him magnus needs to step it up
or it will be game over for him
tomorrow which is today which is now
because we are about to lift off
set six hikaru nakamura needs one win
to win the finals madness carlson needs
to win on demand
and then again win tomorrow if he
has to win the finals so that's two sets
for magnus required and one set for
for hikaru uh miguel writing in with the
finance between hikaru and magnus is
some of the most entertaining chess i've
seen in a long time i think this
this has been the driving point for all
of us watching it just that
the chess has been such high class and
uh absolutely phenomenal to watch it's
been educational
it's been out of the world it's been
brilliancies they've had the human
moments of mistakes we've seen
time pressure we've seen nerves come
into play
entertaining chess for us uh but for
these two guys playing over the board
it's uh it's it's been an
epic epic battle both players in top
form extremely even score
low amounts of draws absolutely i think
uh
that's one of the things with online
chess the nature of online chess
is that we know we're fighting for a
result and especially with this format
you know when you've got a blitz
tiebreak as well
as an armageddon incoming we know that
we are in
for a result at the end of the day
regardless of how
any one format on that particular day
goes absolutely ridiculous match today
hikaru coming back in the second blitz
match was a
bloody master class if you ever consider
getting into watching playing chess
now is the time i could not agree more
with that
i think i think this
uh the last couple of months and the
very very challenging uh situation that
we've all been with and dealing with in
our own way chess has been this
incredibly positive tool
with such an amazing impact on all of us
chess 24's response to the pandemic with
the world champion has been to put this
magnus carlson chess tour together
with incredible analysts on board
breaking down the action for us
and it's been just an amazing journey
and if you have enjoyed it and you
have been a part of it and you want to
see more of this upcoming
definitely consider investing in your
own chess education improving your own
game
and you can do that by going premium on
chess 24 with unlimited
access to some of the best
learning material out there with courses
from world champion from top grand
masters but
also have a very very positive impact on
the community through chess because 50
of all premium membership goes to kiva
during this final and currently there's
also a 30
off on premium membership peter walsh
with it's hard to overstate how exciting
this match has been
madness has been dominating traditional
slow chess for years and he's been
winning handily in online
hikaru has not had great success but
could now win
a big big day coming up for all of us
let's move
on we there was just so much so much
conversation on twitter and of course we
we
would love to have all of it on but we
have only a couple of minutes before
games start
and we had siddhar writing in with if
you want watching the magnus carlsen
tour finals
you are missing out on the greatest
drama of the year
by far this is the match of 2020. this
is the world championship of 2020 at
least as far as online chess is
concerned this
is the fight of fights the battle of
battles this this
these are the two best players of online
chess in 2020
having a major face off and
uh sawmill with over the past few days
we've witnessed some amazing chess which
makes me wonder as to what it would be
like if some player from the past were
to play
again say magnus or hikaru moffee where
is he car
what would that be like i think this is
a great time because i see we are joined
by
our chess experts and our analysts grand
master yasser sarawan and grand master
peter lecker
in the house welcome thank you tanya
hello everyone thank you so much for
sharing your day
and joining us for this magnus carlson
tour finals benefiting
kiva it's really been a pleasure for
peter and i to call the action and for
tonya to be hosting and sharing all your
tweets with us
as we were coming onto the show peter
and i were just having a
discussion and uh peter used a
nice term is today judgment day peter
yeah hello hello tanya exactly that's
the big question i mean uh
hikaru has the the match in the hands if
he
managed to win today but that's exactly
the situation
what magnus wants to avoid and i believe
magnus will give everything what he has
in today's match but in order to do that
maybe the most important thing is to to
calm down
control his nerves and don't let
emotions play any role
just to focus like a machine on playing
what he can do best
playing chess and then hikaru might have
problems finishing this match off but i
mean
what hikaru has shown yesterday with his
incredible comeback
i mean if he if he wins the final it's
uh it's absolutely perfectly
understandable because he has played
such a friendly notches
a phenomenal match indeed peter and
uh we had an interesting question from
our uh
viewer about what it would be like if we
had old
uh the his legends from history play
against players from
from the strongest players of today's
time this has been a conversation that's
been happening throughout the tour
my take on that is that i think if you
had
legends from the past play against
players from today without any catch-up
time i think
players like magnus carlsen anish kiri
hikaru
i i think they would crush them
your take no question tanya i'm with you
100
i think it would be a wipeout keep in
mind that these wonderful wonderful
legends of the past
the max ervis as well as the paul
morphes
max irva was a mathematics teacher
he wasn't a professional player today's
professionals
are just that they're professional they
dedicated
their lives to their crafts and a lot of
the players a lot of the legends of the
past
were amateurs so there's no question to
my mind they get wiped out peter
your your your tape i think uh
you have said everything i don't really
have anything to add it just that
i mean comparing different eras it's
it's just not fair i mean
all the champions were just brilliant in
their times that's why they were the
champions
but chess has evolved and chess has
became so much more than just
playing chess basically the the
computers had
incredible influence and all the modern
players had to adjust their play
and they learned a lot from computers
it's like
uh human touch and the artificial
intelligence combined
so it's understandable that the modern
players right now
have better understanding of the game
absolutely and we've got a little less
than a minute before kickoff actually
the
games are about to start and we see uh
magnus and hikaru
have taken their seats magnus doesn't
look very very happy right now and we
see another other kind
we saw magnus employ this opening
yesterday in the first blitz game with
absolutely incredible result uh let's
see what happens today but it's a trance
it's not the alkyne i didn't see the
deep pawn on d4 my band
it's not the alakan at all i think that
was just for one blitz game but let's
let's get peter and he has to take us
through the action all right thank you
tanya mister just by a smidge that e4
versus d4 yep we got a
we've got a nimzo and you know uh
peter uh the uh a2 a3
gosh darn it of the nimzo oh
the sameish the same ish was terrible in
that armageddon game it's amazing that
magnus actually
missed a golden opportunity to
provincially uh
to possibly equalize a game but the same
ish backfired badly
he didn't play it he played the
rubinstein with e2e3
uh over to you peter yes
i mean i think that tanya mentioned that
it's the alekhine
uh it it shows that how excited we all
are
i mean uh this is just an incredible
fight but yeah this is not the nimzo
indian a very classical battlefield
uh magnus is playing with bishop dc
knight g2 set up
i mean this is not that popular but
had been played a lot and we can see
also the move order from
hikaru that hikaru played the move c5
instead of d5 because if you played d5
actually it's the move order i'm using
so it's nothing against d5
but it does divide the chance of fixing
the pawn structure with c takes d5 e
takes d5
knight g2 getting into some very very
complex
double h strategical fight but with the
move over there with c5 basically black
makes sure that white is not getting
this pawn structure
so after c5 knight g2 d5 nah
this is something maybe what i mean it's
not exactly what magnus hoped for i
believe because
i like the other setup very much for
black i understand why it has perfect
play
so does black but here this is something
much more solid for black and a3
i think we will see a lot of exchanges
invite might have some
microscopic advantage but when you feel
like you want
more out of the position or you want a
very sharp struggle
then this is maybe not exactly what you
are looking for
and thank you for that uh peter i i
that this is a throwback to the 1978
world championship match between
anatoly karpath and victor korchnoy from
baguio city the philippines
and i remember them discussing this
variation bishop c3
knight c3 takes on d4 takes on d4 takes
on c4 knight c6 bishop
e3 and victor well he didn't really get
too much that hence he's recaptured with
a pawn
on a c3 b2 takes c3 uh
re a center peter but um
[Music]
in my mind it that this always leaves
the question for white
what is he gonna do with his dark square
bishop peter
yes but to be honest what i mentioned
uh that it might simplify the situation
this is not the case now after hd
because after ac bishop takes system b
takes c3
white really wants to make sure that he
gets a double edge type of positions
okay this is not the big question in
fact in my mind it's not a big question
that black should simply take d take c4
and yes d take c4 on the board followed
by queen c7
white plays the move bishop a2 and i'm
very curious to see what hikaru
gonna play now because black has two
different moves
but uh okay i believe he he gonna play
b6
right b6 bishop a6 so from
black's point of view the light squared
bishop on c8
you have to ask yourself yes i am i'm
going to interrupt you for just one
second because we have to address what's
going on i mean have you seen
uh magnus on the webcam he looks
extremely uneasy right now
and uh i i don't know it looks
like he's not happy at all it's got
nothing to do with the position because
it's clearly just the opening phase the
two are very well prepared
but from the very start he's he's
something is not all right i don't know
what is your reading of just what's
going on on the webcam right now
you're right he's got a kind of a grumpy
expression to be sure and furthermore
he's not you wearing his usual uh
sponsored dress shirt with uh
all the nice decals that we're used to
seeing um
he looks discombobulated
uh i and you're right i i have i have no
idea what's
what's happening with him at the moment
because it's not the position
he's got a double-edged position that
peter said
he is trying for so your speculation's
as good as mine the california cool look
has definitely gone on hold right now um
no idea what's going on but uh yes tell
us about this opening and what are the
general plans for white
and black i was about to say if you take
the last few moves
back peter there was a bishop on c8
and the question from from black's
perspective with
also the move b7 b6 just take that back
so black black's bishop on c8 it needs a
life
so you've got two ideas one idea is to
play e6
e5 so that the bishop can come out
whether to
f5 or the g4 or potentially the e
e6 so that's one consideration to play
for e6 e5
and the other and the one that you liked
as well as hikaru peter
is to go b6 and play not
to feed shadow of the bishop but maybe
to what i call a accelerated fianchetto
put it on a6 so you're hitting uh
the square c4 the knight on e2 peter
exactly i mean the bishop a6 is the is
the move in this position because
usually in this type of positions it's
very rare that the white knight is on e2
and the bishop on a2 usually the knight
is on f3
bishop might come back to d3 and we have
seen hundreds of
games like that and in that case also
black has the option of simply playing
bishop b7 and
playing a type of position or trying to
exchange the light squared bishops with
bishop a6
now when white has his bishop on a2 and
the knight on e2
there are some new dynamics in the
possession and we also
seen magnus playing the move look c1
very quickly
because he has to make sure that if
black plays the move knight a5 then he's
ready to
play the move c3c for opening up the
long diagonal
and these are the type of positions that
black has to be careful because if he is
able to
deal nicely with white's uh
advance in the center then he will have
a perfect position
but if something goes wrong then things
can really
just collapse so the first moves are
very very important here
all right and uh it sorry uh
just kind of getting the zen of the
position myself for a moment here peter
your move knight a5 as you say you don't
want to see
a bishop land on c4 or even a knight
but your c4 c3 c4 could that be met
by a capture on d4 peter
well if i remember then this is not
so good i mean i'm pretty sure that i
have this in my repertoire and
it's also the game between magnus carson
and levon aronia and i think in one of
the branches two
rapid games they had been debating this
position but it was like three
three years at least yes three years ago
oh nobody here i mean tanya said it
feels like ancient history the match
between dingler in
already so three years ago man you know
that's the statue of limitations was
expired there
but i'm thinking that uh you know i
gotta i've gotta support my presidency
of the pawn grubbers club
and uh i was thinking that in case of
knight takes d4 i would actually just
captured
uh uh the the pawn somehow i
guess yeah i guess i have to capture
with the bishop uh
um peter but i mean i have some knight
b5s followed by takes bishop takes f6
queen g4 check and taking on c4 i mean
that looks that looks deadly that looks
very good
go ahead the only question is which move
order to use because i'm also already
quite exhausted and
i mean i mean i think he could start
with like
exactly as you also stated that
everything that happened before this
match
i already don't remember and
and it was and it goes exactly about my
rep i know that this is my repertoire
but how it
exactly supposed to go i'm not that sure
myself however
okay c8 lying c4 i'm not that sure about
that
right and by the way in that final
position i did like what you were saying
there very much peter
knight b5 attacking the queen queen
moves
if you could just show the audience that
that was a very nice
uh variation queen c5 bishop takes
knight takes bishop takes f6
uh yes and
if also you capture on b5 instead of on
f6 the same move queen g4 that's
that's a winner that's a double attack
and white wins so in fact the pawn was
poisonous so that was why we didn't see
knight a5 what do we have instead peter
yeah the move luke ac8 black played i
mean white played of course c4 and black
captured on d4
and martin was taking his time i mean
this is
this is interesting that does he think
that he has
other alternative because he takes d4
looks so natural
absolutely is taking his time and we do
have some information that in fact
uh magnus is suffering from some pretty
bad
backaches from being on the beach about
30 minutes before liftoff so he's in
actual pain right now and which is why
i think we're seeing uh we're seeing him
struggle so much on the webcam
uh so not only does he have to deal with
a very
very strong on point and difficult
hikaru over the board but he's actually
in a lot of pain right now
oh my goodness i remember from ages ago
in an ancient interpolis uh tilburg
tournament here in holland
uh tony miles was had severe back planes
and tony ended up playing on literally
a kind of a hospital gurney on his
tummy and there's some really famous
photos of him
uh laying down making his moves and when
you have a back pain uh
it can be not only disheartening i mean
it's really just simply hard to think
so uh that is a severe news
indeed for magnus carlson fans
yeah actually what you just mentioned
yes sir if the audience
missed out on this occasion please check
out tony ma's pictures because
i think those pictures from the teal
book tournament are just
so amazing i always wonder that what
would happen to me as an opponent if
somebody would be lying there
could i be focused you know i just i
feel
like uh okay how to concentrate so it's
like a
very mixed thing when your opponent is
lying in front of you
now it's terrible news for magnus of
course that he has the terrible
uh the back pins on the other hand
hikaru doesn't see this
right in front of himself so uh this
should not disturb hikaru but it
definitely
disturbed magnus another big question on
the other hand
[Music]
sorry sorry to interrupt you peter we do
have on our broadcast
a picture of a lubamir laboratory
and tony miles uh laying down just as
you were talking so you could see
uh that uh you know that famous image
went around the world when it was played
because
journalists were like what you know yeah
exactly i mean once you saw the picture
you understand what i'm talking about
i mean it's it's a terrible feeling uh
of course uh what to do what to do but
yeah magnus with pain no pain this is
the last i mean it could
potentially be the last day if he is not
winning today's match
today set so i think uh
if the battle hits on then he will
forget about the pain but if things
start to go wrong then it will be very
difficult to
to get this attention away from from the
pain eventually
after uh some
thought there came the move queen c7 e7
uh peter that black got his queen
off of the x-ray on the c file because
it's very very clear that
magnus has the move d4 d5 blasting open
the b
with the diagonal of the bishop on b2 so
he could capture the knight so the move
queen e7
uh acted to defend the knight
simultaneously
preparing a move like knight a5 because
then the capture of the c4 pawn is much
more
edible let's put it that way uh do you
like that move peter
well it's a very very sharp position and
the
queen e7 does look like a stabilizer
after all there was no real good way the
natural move look fd8 would
have run into d4d5 and after he takes d5
bishop takes f6 would be
just uh too deadly the big question is
after queen e7 can write anyway go
play d5 move and magnus has just done it
asked an answer peter indeed he has and
uh one of the things that uh as i got
much better i think i was almost a chess
master
at the the moment i began to understand
that sometimes i can simply lure my
opponent forward that as
he advances he leaves squares behind him
and sometimes it's very very uh useful
to get your opponent to advance the pawn
now that the pawn
is on d5 is it uh attackable in other
words
should i play rook d8 pinning the pawn
or i wasn't going to say suggest to take
the pawn on d5
i was going to suggest or knight a5 but
this
now that i'm i'm noticing it the bishop
on e2 is coming alive peter
yeah but after he takes d5 the very
concrete question that uh
white is facing that his knight on e2 is
hanging so
basically the move d4 d5 cannot be
followed up with the
very natural looking c takes d5 because
of bishop takes e2
so this already means that the move d4
d5
had been a sacrifice and yeah magnus
follows it up with the move rook e1
uh x-raying the queen on e7 and he is
probably
hoping to jump with knight g3 to f5
putting pressure on the long diagonal
against the
weakness on g7 these are the things
usually i would be really scared of from
the black side
not not to let this happen on the other
hand if black has a good reaction
something like d5 d4 is an option also
from black side
just trying to give back the material
but
making sure that after let's say knight
takes d4
i'm gonna go queen d7 and
and i might exchange queens or
at least get some stability
on the other hand the trade if i can put
it like that the trade that has occurred
in that variation
the d4 pawn is missing the e6 pawn is
missing
and as a result of those traded pawns
the rook on e1 is really beautifully
positioned and the bishop on b2
also equally beautifully positioned i
i would want i would prefer to play
white
in this case uh peter yeah
i mean that's clear you have a move like
knight b5 a very nice
move because you open up the diagonal
you keep
this one pair of knights you need this
knight from the right side because
whenever black takes on b5 you get cb5
and both your bishops will be
perfectly opened on the other hand the
knight is
doing a lot of job on b5 targeting a7
pawn heading towards
d6 the long diagonal is open with the
bishop
so yeah d5 d4 is more like an emergency
brake
i just wanted to mention because it's a
thematic way
and if for example magnus would have
started with the move knight g3
with similar ideas like look e1 then a
nicely timed d5 d4 would be very natural
reaction exactly again shutting down
this
bishop on b2 which is the imbalance in
the position knight
versus dark square bishop and that move
d5 d4
uh if it induced bishop takes d4 black
would be happy
so rookie one peter and
maybe well let's just say it's a rare
sighting
ikaru coming into the match has come in
with a very purposeful
idea of playing like nepo
at least as far as the speed is
concerned and
inspired by the openings and defenses of
fabiano
as he's mentioned he's tried to stay on
the ahead on the clock
uh but he hasn't done it uh
this is the first time i'm seeing well
first time is an exaggeration
it's rare to see magnus having so much
uh more time and
we've just seen the move bishop take c4
by hikaru
i wanted to i wanted to ask you the
question though
would would you suggest that uh
preparation
goes to uh magnus in this game
i'm not sure that there is so much
preparation involved here it's
it's more like magnus wanted to play a
type of position
i'm not sure that he anticipated the
move of their c5 or did he anticipate
the move of the d5 and which one he
he focused on more in any case when
finally
the white player who plays this nimzo
india instant relation with e3
and prefers to go knight g2 basically it
indicates that he
simply agrees to play this type of
position he understands that it's not
about advantage it's more
much more about complexity of the
position he wants to keep as many pieces
possible on the board and play a long
game
on the other hand now we have we have
seen some very
concrete action right the big question
is now
how magnus will justify his his
sacrifices because he has already
sacrificed two pawns of course
he can take back one but then the whole
point of his
concept would would be spoiled so
i believe that he has to kind he already
started the gamble he has to go along
that way
and prove it that it was not a gamble
it's all perfectly summed and the move
nigestly played
and queen d8 bleeds down black has to
control the f6
knight because okay another rook is open
knight is heading towards f5 but white
has to
lose a tempo not to deal with this
bishop on c4 whether you take it which
is not
really an option i believe or to go
bishop b1 and say that yeah i'm two
pawns down but i have initiative
yeah somehow it's like uh
magnus definitely wants to seize the
initiative to
push the attack and we've been seeing
him
trying to do that i don't know if he's
uh
he's overdone it a little bit here i
i'm skeptical i just want to put it that
way i hate the idea of
you know you've sacrificed two pawns now
let's trade bishops
i hate the idea of bishop take c four
but if i have to play the move bishop b1
and i kind of think he has to play the
move bishop
b1 frankly uh i feel that it is a bit of
gambling
on magnus's part
yeah i have the same feeling because
let's not forget that yes if white plays
bishop b1
the bishop on c4 is hanging so black
cannot play the d5 d4 move yet
but i mean d5 d4 will be there even if
you first protect your bishop somehow
and then when y goes knight f5 you play
the move d4
so not entirely clear what magnus
sword i mean first of all if we go back
to queen e7
it was not like d4 d5 was forced yeah
absolutely that was kind of setting
knight a5 and one can argue that yeah
once you get knight e5 then
any kind of d4 d5 breaks will be too
late
so magnus might have felt that simply d4
d5
is the principal move and he just
decided to go for it
without really knowing how he will
continue
[Music]
yeah and uh well more or less we
in fact quite more uh they played
down exactly what we intuited as well
that this should be
one whether you like it or not that's
the move you got to play you got to keep
your attacking forces
uh icaru played b5 uh fortifying the
bishop
on c4 so that he could play d5 d4
knight f5 the knight on g3 jumps in the
game
by the way knight g7 alert alert alert
you know
after you see a knight landing on f5 you
have to
uh be aware that danger
is on your doorstep d5 d4 absolutely
the most natural movement in the
position in my view shutting down that
bishop on b2
hoping to get some trades and magnus
says no thank you i don't want to trade
you keep your lousy pawns
i want to attack queen d2 with
telegraphing
queen g5 peter yes
queen g5 is a big threat
and hikaru played the move bishop e6
like
saying okay i know this bishop on c4 was
great but
i'm not liking this knight on f5
and that two pawns up maybe let me just
eliminate this knight and
uh if i do that then do we have enough
resources to pause my king some problems
i believe the answer is no to that
question but
simply once black takes on f5 for
example after
move like queen g5 bishop takes f5 queen
f5
maybe black will not be able to
hold on to to all his pawns but again
this is not something black is really
concerned about because
okay he's two pawns up uh let's just
exchange some more pieces and
maybe i will even end up being pulled up
so i don't believe queen g5
is the idea of magnus but uh
but what exactly indeed uh what exactly
uh i thought it was desi that there's a
swish and zug in the position that is
off-putting
i thought that knight takes d4 knight
takes d4
rook takes c8 might be a favorable
continuation by white
only to fall for a very nice uh
swizzenzug
knight f3 check oops i'd hope to be able
to recapture on d4 with
a queen but that is off-putting and
if i take on d4 with the bishop then i'm
thinking that rook takes c1 and again
the the tempest in the storm has rather
passed uh magnus
eschewing all of those ideas peter
uh again i i've used this term
throughout the broadcast
but it really feels to me like the
players
want to play a type of chess which they
know
is is marvelously entertaining
upping the ante is magnus carlson with
the move rook c5
and peter i gotta say that visually
that's exactly the type of moves
that the position is calling out for
more activity of the pieces
yes that's true on the other hand this
whole concept by magnus yeah going for
this very aggressive approach
somehow signals me that he is maybe too
impulsive
i mean i i talked at the beginning of
the broadcast
that uh one of the key factors i believe
for magnus today is that he should calm
down
and try to play the chess that he's best
in
and i'm not exactly sure that uh going
for all this gamble and all this very
sharp direct attempt with
uh still so so much time i mean right
from the beginning when your opponent
still has so much time now
we see that it was it was and it's still
probably not an easy task for hikaru to
handle the situation that's why
we see five and a half minutes on the
clock on the other hand since he was
faced with this uh
right from the beginning he had time to
adjust to the situation
okay if magnus gonna win this game then
we will say it was a brilliant strategy
right now i'm not not entirely sure
indeed the jury is definitely out hikaru
is saying
i'm not exactly sure what is going on
here what i should be afraid of
but i'm a couple of pawns in the in the
pocket let me just keep one a7 a6
your turn mr world champion show
yeah well i mean uh
yes suddenly i didn't hear you
uh oh ah nah it's back yeah nice okay
yeah i got a signal there that my my
microphone went
doink i was like but you know i
understand
and everybody says that technology is
always cool no it's not cool at all i
mean there is so much tension so much at
stake that
i mean anything can happen to to us and
to the technology and
and to the players as well i mean
the movie a6 i don't know what to think
about it
it really signals that i don't believe
that you have an attack going
right and i want to protect my b5 form
because it's not just the pawn but it
covers very important squares
on the other hand okay there was an
option of simply eliminating this knight
on f5
right okay probably white captures them
back on f5 with the bishop it's a tempo
you have to play the move look c7 and
then
ah the invite has the move look fc1 yeah
it's not only about the pawn but also
about some pins
okay black can still play move like
queen d6 but
yeah this explains why hikaru doesn't
want to
to let this happen he he wants to
stabilize first
bit but you you went right into my line
of thought as well that the move
rook c5 peter had the double
uh intention of taking the pawn on b5
thank you very much that's a
that's a that's a nice pawn but also
doubling
so isn't isn't doubling uh
there is of course the tactic of 97
checks so defending the the
the knight on c6 so rook c1 queen d7
would be a howler
well hold on well knight takes g7
happened yeah that was
that was exactly my concern with a6 that
do you have this time
to to avoid on the other hand not so
easy to see the follow-up
i mean one feels that there is something
but what
exactly is another question okay well
let's see if we can't uh figure it out
uh peter uh this bishop on b2
it it really really rook c6 bishop d4
ridiculous peter
yeah that feels too much but if it turns
out to be right then
okay after bishop thinks if i have moves
like h6
stopping the queen g5 desire yeah
magnus played the move queen g5 check
and queen h4
that was also my follow-up but the big
question was for me
what next so the difference here
is that with the bishop on b1 the
h7 pawn is under attack so there's no
knight g8 some kind of consolidating
move no no no no that knight is
frozen um rook c6 bishop takes d4
is definitely on white's agenda now
rook takes c6 bishop takes d4 with that
would have the dual threat
of bishop f6 and queen h7 and
i don't know if knight g7 was forced i i
was thinking rook e1c1 looked
attractive but if this works this is
genius
uh just just the genius
uh peter if it works
yeah well i mean it it looks promising i
don't know if
if it really kills or whatever i mean
feeling wise when you see a move like a6
there is immediately this
feeling that oh but what happens after
takes takes
a queen g5 check on the other hand
i believe that hikaru must have force in
it i
i cannot still imagine hikaru not
sensing the danger here but
uh maybe he missed something and then if
he misses something with
little time on the clock it it might be
very very unpleasant
exactly also just boldly pointing out
the obvious a move like bishop d5
anticipating that rook takes c6 rook
takes c6
the rook on c6 makes a nice defensive
impression
rook takes d5 oops that would be very
very very painful
indeed for uh uh for black so
no bishop d5 don't think about that um
peter as as i'm looking i i i want to
see a defense i i
am i'm fighting to see the defense
uh rook g8 just it's
while it's a desirable move i want to
play rook g4
i just think that rook takes c6 comes
too fast
yeah look take c6 comes and after luke
takes c6 bishop takes d4
you have you don't have time for g4 do
you have
i mean yeah i was thinking like
bishop d5 defends the the knight
brilliantly on f6 but queen h7 is rather
embarrassing
yeah this is the typical mating motif
here with the bishop d4 and
bishop on d5 bishop on b1 so something
like look takes g2 but
also g2 doesn't do much because even
after king g2
something like bishop d5 check
okay i have many options fc king it
definitely
it feels like a spike check that rook
takes g2
actually so uh not good
not good um let's go back to the current
position
and what else could black
be considering that there's a back
ranked mate
threat right peter uh for
for for white his so uh the rook on e1
needs to go
um how do i do this so
rook e8 rook c6 rook c6 bishop d4
i do have bishop f5
oh my god that would be crazy uh because
i'm trying to
i'm trying to make i'm trying to make a
back rank checkmate peter uh
uh is that ridiculous line no no not at
all ridiculous i mean
something along this this way it should
be the solution for black how to
how to count the strike yeah yeah but i
feel myself
i'm doing some desperado things i feel
like but
maybe i'm forced to be uh desperate
peter
yeah look at also hikaru's cloak i mean
he is down to
130 on his clock so he desperately needs
uh
desperate measures i mean just there is
no simple way to defend
no and you spotted this back rank issue
very nicely but hikaru did play the move
loop g8
okay i don't see that
i mean a kind of a first intention right
because you really desperately want to
play rook g4
and drive away the attacking
queen but i thought that unfortunately
rook c6 and bishop d4 was just too fast
peter just way too fast yeah okay the
move looked like c6 has to be played
it's clear
and we should try to understand what
hikaru bases his defense on yeah does he
want to play
bishop d no bishop d5
wow then f6 is hanging with check yeah
yeah yeah that's that is absolutely true
uh peter but i mean exactly that
variation is not the end of the world
because after
takes takes luke takes g2 check i have
to go to f1 and then you go look
f look cg8 and you are threatening
bishop c4 check followed by look g1
checkmate
wow i mean okay it shouldn't work i have
moves like bishop dc
but it's a bit scary at least yeah or
king e2
actually crazily enough white is
actually a piece up in this
uh variation i mean he was a piece down
and suddenly i i've a piece up and we
have the position on the board
with rook takes c6 rook takes c6 bishop
takes d4
and here i'm coming up empty queen h7
mate mate in oh my goodness king g7
i didn't see that move uh peter no i saw
the move
but i mean it looked very very
suspicious so i
i wanted to find a different alternative
i somehow suspect that the only way for
black was luke 8 bishop f5 these
incredible wrestlers that you
you def you've discovered because that
one felt very much in the spirit but
just like this trying to run out with
the king
i don't uh i don't believe that black
can survive
[Music]
in the parlance of the british looks
dodgy uh
queen g5 check peter king f8
queen h6 check king e8 bishop
takes f6 well this is exactly what
magnus is doing but with an improved
version by
taking on h7 immediately h7
check yeah king f8 queen a6 checking e8
bishop takes f6 and
and here we are same variation with a
missing h7 pawn
so uh white is an exchange
down but that's not what the position is
about what the position is about
is that black's king got blown
off from the king side uh and is now
uh residing on e8 queen
a5 peter attacking the rook on e1
yes i mean hikaru feels like he has to
create some counter chances by hitting
white's weak first
rank and in this respect queen is a very
very nice
little touch because instead of
continuing desperately to attack black's
king
magnus realizes that okay i have
everything under control i have
wonderful compensation in fact
one can even argue that did white
sacrifice anything because after all
white is a pawn and a very powerful
bishop for the rook
and it flex the black centralized king
on e8 doesn't make a good impression
so just by not letting black get any
counter play
white stabilizes and will continue the
attack
exactly the desirable rook d1
might have been met by rook d6
uh and again strangely enough uh
hikaru's uh backrank check uh
chances or something i was looking for
him as well
he's found it i like this move queen e3
up a lot peter because
oops let's just jump to the current
position after queen e3
how did the game continue sorry yeah
hikaru challenged this queen on
easy with the move queen b6 yeah very
nice move because okay the queen on east
is just too powerful and i wonder
whether did magnus maybe miss something
he blitzed out the move rook d1
and luke d6 bleeds down by hikaru as if
he is quite relieved with
what has happened in the last two moves
whoa
i didn't like rook d1 i was thinking
that just some a simple move queen e4 uh
you know maybe angling for queen h7 uh
or even for that matter bishop d4 bit
the bishop on f6 looks
good uh i'm not sure rook d1
that looks like a slip to to my eyes at
least uh
peter yeah absolutely i mean uh black
gets uh
to trade something off i mean simply i
believe that magnus felt that rook d6 is
not possible because
uh because it's simply not possible the
queen on b6 is hanging and the lugia
checkmate is happening
sometimes you rush and you hallucinate
with something
yeah and hikaru using immediately this
option with rook d6
and now white has to trade rook so has
to trade queens i mean
uh i don't know i mean he can't he can't
trade queens at all because of luke
takes d1
checkmate i don't like those choices
bishop d4 is
not happiness but i prefer bishop d4
over the alternatives you were
mentioning uh by the way just show it
for the audience
uh the desirable queen takes b6
rook takes b6 rook d8 checkmate is
brilliant
except you get checkmated when
rook takes d1 gives it a back rank
checkmate to black
so that was why uh it's
possible magnus said you can't play rook
d6 because of queen b6
and only when he got there said oh man
i just allowed that slip and queen c6
and
again it's the tenacity of hikaru
in somehow finding chances in a position
well let's let's be fair was horrible
for hikaru
yeah it looked horrible and he was also
very low on time magnus still
was in comfortable situation and all of
a sudden
position might still be very nice
compensation but the spin along the
d-file is really annoying
and what is even more annoying that
magnus is done to 33 seconds on the
clock
i mean in this very sharp position this
is very very tricky
wow okay well i mean we've been seeing
all of these back rank
issues and uh for those of you who are
wondering
why is magnus off screen
uh we've been told that he's suffering a
back injury he's has some back pain
so he's looking for a comfortable
position and unfortunately
it means that he's not on camera for
ourselves who are watching for sure for
the
uh arbiters he's on camera and h2h3
getting out of these back rank mates
makes
sense to me uh peter even considered h4
by the way
and then king d7 the king on e8 was
terrible
uh a little bit better on d7 um
i just have a feeling i think in a
practical game i prefer
white but three results here peter
absolutely three results i mean all
these pins along the e
and d file means that you can't really
play
by your hand and if you can't really
play by your hand
uh then then it's it's very tough okay
magnus played the move king h2
finally getting out of this quincy one
check so
now he is already kind of intending to
move his bishop
and so he's solving this uh this spin
issue along the d file if he managed to
solve that
then all of a sudden his position will
again look very very nice
so what at absolutely huge
huge decisions being made with seconds
on the clock again there is a 10 second
bonus
for each move completed but man i tell
you i feel nervous when i'm down to five
minutes
never mind when i'm down to 19 seconds
and magnus carlsen
uh a clock is ticking those 10 seconds
go really
fast by the way bishop d5
that wasn't the move i was looking at uh
bishop f5 and
uh i think that this is the ideal
uh moment now for he for magnus to solve
his pin there's no more queen c1 why not
bishop
e5 peter well magnus actually chose the
move bishop dc also
very tempting move because he's solving
yeah he's solving beautifully the
problem of the pin yeah black cannot
capture the d4 pawn because of bishop
takes b5 tactics
i mean it might look like yeah this is
very simple tactics but with 10 seconds
on the clock
to spot these nice intermediate ideas
are not not simple at all not
not easy at all indeed and that's a
beautiful
one what a way of solving the pin
along the d file and six seconds
ooh and hikaru with six seconds made the
move
actually i think it was even three
seconds he made the queen a4
and bishop e5 very quickly peter it
looks like magnus has crashed through
with queen a7 this looks like it's it's
over it looks terrible
and magnus won the game he resigned it
was clear once black gets
one single check it's game over and
magnus managed to
remove the bishop from from d4 with the
tempo
and maybe hikaru blundered the move
queen a7 but
with few seconds on the clock once might
this solve this uh
pinning issues then the black king on d7
was just way too naked and there was no
way to survive this
if you would go back to the position
before the move bishop the e5 because
just before that move yeah right here
it really felt like you know i don't
know
a move like king c8 or you
know no king c8 walks into rook c2 i
apologize yeah king c8 walks into rook
c2
but here you know
there's got to be some some ways for for
for black to make the position um tricky
let's put it that way i don't think it's
it's just a winning position
for white yeah i i fully agree with you
definitely not winning on the other hand
imagine hikaru has something like 40
seconds
right and after the move king h2 white
finally can lean back that
okay i'm about to to solve this pin
issue i don't know exactly
how i will benefit the most and black
wants to make a move but he doesn't see
which move to make
the there are no no real obvious moves
time is ticking down and finally you
make a nervous move like
okay let me play bishop d5 without even
having the chance of thinking what are
the consequences behind your move
right and after bishop f5 check bishop
e6 bishop dc
uh brilliant little tactic by magnus
it's probably not that it's game over
exactly
well a huge huge way of starting this
sixth
set as magnus needs to win to the set to
force a seventh set he starts with the
white pieces
and yeah i mean
he went for it i think he was gambling
peter but
it paid off i mean two uh
to the brave goes victory
tanya what a way of starting the six set
i think uncompromising chess
i mean yes i don't even know why you're
surprised anymore because this is just
the kind of chess that we've gotten used
to
in this final absolutely combative and
uncompromising as you put it but that's
the need of the hour the world champion
needs to take his chances
and to create them and you were spot on
that was a chance that happened when
hikaru went a6
even moving back with the bishop to e6
was something that perhaps was not the
most accurate move because it allows
this rook c5
rook lift which can be transferred to
the king side as well as threatens
doubling on the c file but a6 was the
big turning point knight g7 spotted by
the world champion
instantly was the right way to go but
then
the critical moment was after queen b6
both players
uh it's already very difficult this
position
and uh after rook g8 it was this rook c6
bishop d4 just explodes black's position
and white is doing incredibly well after
that rookie it was in fact uh
an inaccuracy and if we just move back a
little bit
let's just go back a couple of moves
yeah so here right when queen h4 and
your g8 rook c6 happen and the position
with queen b6 if we could just bring
that up
one second when yes right about here now
this was the moment and you were totally
right yes all madness had to do here was
move the queen away perhaps to f3
or do we f3 is is a good square because
the idea is very simple what black
what white wants to do is go h4 h5 8687
and it's with the king in the center and
absolutely no coordination in black
pieces
nothing no chances to create at all this
would have been game over rook t1 was a
big moment for hikaru to strike back
and get some balance and he did root b6
was exactly the kind of move that needed
to be played
and after magnus went at bishop d4
one of the very interesting lines given
by the computer here because the rook is
still pinned on d1 is actually you don't
need to move the queen from b6 just
about yet
but you need to create your chances how
does black do that is with a move like
b4
trying to get in on the
just trying to break open so that you
can create some chances along
open files and here for example white
white could go f4 just one of the
options of course a very very messy
position
and difficult to say the game can go
anywhere but just an interesting line
after f4 black simply takes on a3
sacrificing the queen but has
maintained a balance because after
bishop b6 you take
rook to d1 you take the rook on d1 king
after you pick up the bishop on b1
and it's a it's one big mess on the
board this a pawn gives a lot of
compensation
uh completely unclear it was a big
opportunity for for hikaru try and save
and of course as usual
there are so many lines and and the
players playing on seconds
just anything can happen because this is
exactly
those kind of positions in which if you
are fighting the clock or playing on
seconds
mistakes are going to happen these two
of course world-class players playing
playing very very close to computer top
lines faltered here and
uh magnus took his chances and now
leads so he's he's done what needed to
be done
at the start of the day he's won his
first game
with the white pieces hikaru nakamura
has to try and level the score
three more rapid games to go the
excitement of course continues but
a bit of a relief for the world
champions band and
uh we've been seeing that let's take a
look at what hikaru had to say coming
into today's um
today's set and let's play that
of course hikari just saying bring it on
there and
uh he's ready for it and that's what the
world champ
did he he showed some excellent prep
there
got his chances out of the opening took
them and had the opportunity when he
went knight g7
and that was that was all one inaccuracy
from the world champion
but uh hikaru could not make the most of
it
we of course got lots of lots of as you
can see
yes peter i don't know if you noticed
the bar below the screen while you were
talking and while you were commentating
uh the green has just has just is just
inching its way to our goal and it's
it's absolutely phenomenal to see the
kind of support
that we've had throughout by our amazing
audience which of course inspired by the
chess that they have been seeing uh
invest in in their own education by
going premium and also supporting kivas
campaign this is the amount of money
that we have raised as a community
to give back to the community through
chess by going premium and it's not just
been the support of
uh all of our incredible audience but
also grand masters across the world
have come forward to support the cause
we've had
grand master ding lehren we've had
magnus carlsen we've had anish we've had
vasa levant
grand master peter lecko and many many
others and today we also received
another big donation
shout out to grandmaster pascal who is
making a big contribution of one
thousand dollars a worth of premium
memberships
which will be given to brooklyn is 318
chess team
and uh it's uh it's a charity that uh
pascal supports uh so he has
uh he he will be gifting out the
memberships to the students over there
and this is another way that you can
contribute
by uh by buying by gifting premium
membership to your friends to your
families to
to young talents across the world you
could either buy the membership for
yourself or donate
uh donate the premium and of course as
always just
unlimited access to to all the to the
library to the intensive
improving your chess library 30 off on
premium membership currently using the
code
kiba finals but of course the news for
that just doesn't stop we've had anish
giri with his opening repertoire pose
the french we've had the magnus touch
dropping the end game cost
and we also have grand master yasas
sarahan score so we've got
we've got the opening taken care of and
we've got the end game taken care of and
now we also have the middle game with
winning strategies
by yasa sarawan uh take a look at this
okay this guy gets the big bucks like
so definitely visit chessable.com and
check out these intensive
entertaining and educational courses
you've got anish kerry taking care of
your openings yes are taking care of
your middle games and magnus carlsen
taking care of your end games
i i think if you started all three you
would be playing some superhuman chess
right there what's required right now is
of course for hikaru to be playing some
superhuman chess because he is playing
catch up to magnus carlsen's win in
round one hikaru will be playing
with the white pieces next peter yas
what needs to be done
what are we expecting in the opening
phase boy tanya i must say i'm still
reeling from the outcome of this game
that
was a really uh scintillating attack i'm
still
i'm knight g7 led to that winning
position
i'm sure there had to be a defense there
somewhere uh
but it re remarkable and if i'm in a car
shoes i'm just thinking okay
catch a deep breath because that was
quite a blow
and just get back to what got you the
lead right
uh just play good chess stay ahead on
the clock
and peter for this particular game again
i mean
it felt like magnus you know he got the
opening he stayed ahead on the clock
himself and he was ultimately rewarded
with
uh quite an attacking victory yeah
absolutely stunning game by magnus
carson
it was clear that white has initiative
but some high fat like if black is able
to block the position with the timely d5
d4 then divorce has passed for black
and white is simply two points down
with compensation definitely but one had
the feeling not more than enough
compensation
and then all of a sudden knight takes g7
happened
and practically speaking when your clock
is ticking down you have like
maybe four minutes to to solve the issue
and you are also
like in state of shock uh it's uh it's
very very tough because
believe me if somebody tells you that
this is a
this is a puzzle for you to solve
and you know that there is a defense so
i mean that there is a solution to
different black exposition then it's
much easier to to find that defensive
when you are actually very angry how
could i
give this opportunity for magnus of
course he's crushing mina and so on
once you have all those thoughts finding
your defense is
basically i think simply impossible and
especially with so very little time
tanya
yes absolutely yes and like you were
saying that you know you
you feel like there should be a defense
for black here
uh you are right about that in some way
and i just quickly want to take you
through a line but actually 97 is still
a
very very powerful sacrifice this move
a6 of course gives
white this huge opportunity and the only
way that black could have handled it
of course very difficult to find and
i've had the help of the computer to
help me look at this
but a very instructive and a very
creative line take a look at this guys
king g7
queen g5 check is correct king h8 queen
h1 like i was mentioning after rook jade
it all falls apart for
uh four black but here black had an
interesting move rook to e8
and the point is that one of the biggest
the problems in white's position
that black needs to make the most of
instantly is the back rank weakness so
that's how you're going to counter it
and here the top move the top line of
the engine is the move like g3 it's a
big mess on the board
the sacrifice is still very sound
because black's position
is he's still in a lot of trouble these
two bishops on b2 b1
are uh are extremely strong and
dangerous
here black could think about running
away with the king as well with a move
like
king to g7 or king to g8 and the game
continues
but instead of g3 let's take a look at
what happens
if white plays the most dangerous
looking move which is rook
takes c6 if you grab it with the same
idea the difference is that after bishop
d4 you have this huge threat of mate on
8 7 because of the pin along the a1 h8
diagonal
but black's got a really pretty move
here and it's bishop to f5
taking advantage of exactly the
background weakness that we've been
talking about and let's trade off some
pieces it doesn't matter whether you
start with bishop f6
or you start with rookie but let's say
bishop f6 rook to f6
and if you play rook e8
queen e8 and after queen f6 black can
just simply move the king to g8 you
can't grab the bishop
on f5 with either the queen or the
bishop because of the threat on e1 and a
move like queen g5 you can just come
back with the bishop
or even move your king away with bishop
g6 is the simplest answer
rookie it had to be played to develop
immediate and instant counter chances on
the board but when you're playing on
minutes in such a dangerous position
it's extremely difficult
to find the accuracy and like you
mentioned yes
nobody is there to tell you that you
know this is the point that you need to
slow down
and have a look uh that's
my biggest complaint about those
tactical puzzle books tanya
is when you have a tactical puzzle book
you know there's a solution
but you know sometimes your combinations
boomerang
you know not all combinations work over
the board unfortunately
uh we we we thought about rookie 8
because again that back rank
uh made threads but boy you know finding
all of those moves including bishop
f5 i i have to say peter and i are
not under the pressure of the ticking
clock so we're pretty calm we're just
enjoying everything
but it was really hard for us to find
those moves as well
well yes sir it's very nice of you
sharing
uh the discoveries together but actually
it was your move
rookie eight and when you said look
eight it immediately hit my heart that
yes the first rank is
is exactly what you are hoping for so it
was a great
find but we actually have a liftoff of
the second game
absolutely and it could be a potential
berlin incoming and it is on the board
also if you look at the screen uh we can
see that magnus in fact he's in so much
he's in such severe pain that sometimes
to adjust his position he's literally
sitting
on his knees and not the chair
trying to find a comfortable position
and
he does from
from what i can see he's rubbing his
forehead he's he's in anguish tanya this
is not
this is not good this is not good you
almost feel like
uh can we just uh ask for an hour
postponement get some trainer i mean in
in tennis
they allow the trainer to come in and
give a massage in case
of a muscle cramp this could be severe
peter
yeah this is of course terrible
maybe this also explained the reason why
magnus was so aggressive in game one he
felt like he has to play as
quickly as possible and put as much
pressure on the opponent as possible
right from the beginning because
long games don't suit him yeah it's
it's of course a very new situation i
also don't know what to think of it
i might ask if tanya could somehow
uh get some information
is a timeout is not what i'm looking for
i'm looking for a
medical timeout some kind of like can i
just
get a 30 minute stoppage so that
i can get a masseuse in here uh i've
never
seen it really uh in online play
i mean of course people get ill and then
oftentimes the games are simply
postponed
uh in this remote chess that's very
awkward but
i mean i i'm i'm very sympathetic to
magnus looking at him suffering
is not what we want to see and if he
were to request
a 20-minute timeout something of that
nature i would
give it to him if i was an arbiter your
thoughts peter
yeah of course this is the question if
did magnus request that
does he feel that he has the right to
ask that
and how the arbitrary handle the
situation now that
magnus one game one i feel like he feels
that it would simply not be polite
to to ask for any help because he's
leading uh with the
with the score uh this is i think
psychologically also putting some
extra pressure that if the score would
be even then you feel like okay let me
ask the arbiter because okay i really
have this pain
but now he's leading so it's it's a
tough call
it's a really tough call all right fair
enough well we'll let the players suffer
through
their opening moves and peter i i have
the
impression so many of these uh positions
these middle game positions with a2
a4 that we are so familiar with from rui
lopez
uh i wouldn't be surprised at all if
we're still on
uh terra firma in terms of theory
are is this still all theory as far as
you're aware
or are we new peter i think it's
kind of theory but it's uh it's not a
not a thematic line at all because
there are so many move orders and uh
let me just try to explain what has
happened so
after the move these three magnus used
the move d6 which served him
so well on day four of their match
yes i think it was day four yeah and uh
there hikaru always played the most
natural looking move c3 but
the move of their c3 actually give black
the chance to play
the g6 setup because now after d4 okay
first magnus used them on bishop d7
and then in his next game he even used
the move bishop g7
and this is some relatively recent
development from correspondence chess
that black is even able to play bishop
g7
and how i remembered that once black
plays the move d6 it's more precise to
start with
start with castles because if black goes
for the g6 setup you exactly played the
same
line with d3 d4 breaking in the center
but
it turns out that casos is much more
useful than the move c3
right in this regard and after the move
short castle black is actually playing
the move bishop e7 and then you play c3
which would exactly happen if you have
played c3 black plays bishop e7
white would anyway would have castled
yeah
so with the move order shortcut so first
you basically
probably kind of force black of uh going
for the bishop e7 setup
and then you already limited all those
g6 options
that's that's the first thing about the
move order then later
we see a6 bishop a4 castles rookie one
look eight this is a typical type of uh
anti-berlin position but it's now
already anti-spanish anti-marshallish
because
a6 a6 and bishop a4 had been included so
this
basically indicates that it's exactly
the same stuff
like if white is playing oops this
cancels
bishop e7 and d3 and of course here
black has two options
playing with b5 bishop b3 and then d6
which is
very natural and it's the most
frequently used
but black also has the option of playing
d6 when white plays c3 and vr
by move orders into the same position
like it happened in the game
well one of the things that's really
remarkable about
chess openings is the transpositions
that so frequently take place
and one move order brings you to a
same position that a different move
order would also have
i think that what you were pointing out
though peter that was really
remarkably instructional how the early
castles as opposed to c3 was a much more
useful move
and it forced magnus into playing the
black side
of a really low low pass
proper so to speak yeah that's
that's perfectly true and now here we
are seeing one very very important
position which i have in the diagram
because after b5 there are two options
that if you did it with the bishop on c2
then black has this free move d6 d5
and if you want to avoid that then you
have to play the move bishop bc which is
slightly counterintuitive because you
feel like now that my pawn is on c3 i
can
bring my bishop back all the way to c2
i'm winning the tempo
but it does allow d6 d5 if you play them
with bishop b3
then if black plays a move like d6 d5
you have this very nice
typical trick in the spanish i mean
lopez
e takes d5 knight takes d5 d4 and thanks
to the pressure on the d5 knight black
is not able to play e takes d4 because
then
the knight on d5 is hanging
and this is actually the the point
behind bishop bc when
black usually plays a move like knight
a5 bishop c2
c5 and we go towards some triggering
type of
position got it the bishop c2 d5
on the board and the players keep
playing relatively
quickly peter yeah i mean after d5
hikaru played the movie a4 it's the
basically the only
really critical move to challenge black
because
you kind of ask him please show me how
you want to solve your problems on the
on the with the b5 pawn if you're gonna
play b5 b4 that
weakens your structures allows white to
fix the pawn structure with
a4 a5 later the white bishop might
return to a4 putting pressure on the
knight on c6
the pawn on e5 starts to be vulnerable
whenever you exchange on e4 and you get
this dtak c4 dtx e4 structures
it's also easier to play from the right
side because somehow this knight on c6
faces this pawn on c3 so he doesn't
really have any
good squares so magnus's reaction look
b8 is
very very logical he wants to keep the
pawn on b5 limiting white's
bishop on c2 and after a takes b5 8xb5h3
we get a position where i believe black
should be
quite satisfied because it feels like he
has
if not fully but almost fully equalized
um very nice again and again
for me i always have three goals in the
opening
i want my fair share of the center i
want to be able to control
as much of the center as i can but i
want to have a fair share
one effective pieces and i want to save
king
um and the knights on c6
yeah the knight on c6 might be
preferable on g6
but the knight on f6 the bishop on f8
the rook on e8 they make favorable
impressions
what is what is black supposed to be
doing
with his light squared bishop uh peter
does that go on the long diagonal or
does it go to the e6 square
well i think that now that magnus
already made up his mind of
playing rook b8 against the a4 idea that
indicates that he doesn't want to put
his bishop on b7
i i suspect that
magnus wants to bring it to e6 but
once you go bishop e6 then you also see
that white still has some potential of
getting the rook to a6 hitting the
knight on c6 so
not not all that easy to to decide what
to do
and also let's not forget that black has
the option of
actually just changing trading done
along the
center with dtxc4 dtx e4 even
exchanging the queens and uh say that
okay how bad this end game could be but
the problem about
such strategy is that maybe the position
is slightly unpleasant and by fixing the
structure
giving up the center you give free hand
for wide exactly
yeah i don't i'm not a big fan of d5
takes e4 i like
maintaining the tension uh i don't like
uh just for the pro just for the reason
that you were showing that this rook
could
uh place itself on a6 the rook's on this
open
file i'm not a big fan of that
so the rook on b8 doesn't have an open
file peter
let me play the book b5b4 and say i
would like to play
as black b4 takes c3 your rook has the
open a file i would like the open b
file uh how do you like uh b4
peter well if you play b4 then you give
me the option of going bishop a4
okay i'm not sure that that you like
that
but again it's it's not the end of the
world however
you don't have any easy way of dealing
with the pin yeah
you don't want to go bishop this and you
don't want to go bishop b7 but you
still got to do something right and
uh finally magnus did chose the move d
takes e4 but connected with a very very
specific idea so after d for d for queen
d1
look d1 he used his momentum just as you
wanted to
try to open up the b file with the
timely b5 b4 move
well there you go and unfortunately
asked and answered
uh white's reaction to the move b4 has
got to be bishop a4 peter
yeah bishop a4 on the board and magnus
goes bishop b7
[Music]
wow the player i associate with these
type of positions
uh more than anybody else is lavonna
ronian
uh lavone's uh vaunted marshall gambit
has scared so many players into playing
you know the anti-marshals that he seems
to be playing the
anti-marshals more than he's playing the
marshall
itself and unfortunately for you too
peter
uh your martial gambit also terrified
your opponents and they would do
anti-martial
things that we're witnessing in this
game exactly i mean when i see this game
and i follow
all the memories and all those uh
hundreds of hours of analysis of all
these
anti-marshals came back as uh
as memories the point finally why i
give up on marsha was simply that i
never got the marshall going i mean
always as you mentioned white players
started to use the
anti-martial and then the question was
whether i prefer to play the
anti-martial or the anti-berlin because
anyway the people will not give the
berlin end game
and then you have to choose between
these two and
finally it felt to me like maybe the
anti-berlin is even more practical from
the black side
how intriguing and you came one game
short of winning the world championship
and thanks to the marshall
i mean you were just one game away from
becoming world
champion so okay there you have it folks
why he why did peter laiko give up
the martial gambit not because he didn't
like the marshall gambit no no no it's
just that
nobody would play it against him they
were always playing the anti-marshal
and now we have uh the current situation
uh peter it's it just looks a little bit
more comfortable
for white after all this move bishop e3
to set up a type of a deadly threat
connected with rook c1 yes but
somehow black is getting control i mean
okay very very nicely timed and now
white is unable to play look ac one
because of the pin
he has to take care of his bishop on a4
the move
look dc one first of all doesn't have
any threat
because black can take on a1
right at the end of the line so
hikaru says let me first stabilize this
pawn
this bishop on a4 with my pawn with the
move b2b3
protecting the bishop and making rook on
a1 to c1 possible
yeah looks logical peter yeah looks
very logical but knights black to move
and
my feeling is that this one little
half tempo that black goat should be
able for him yeah and look at the eighth
plate exactly that was my instinct
immediately because the point is that
white spawn on e4 is vulnerable as well
so if black i mean white captures on d8
then black has this possibility of
capturing with the knight on d8
opening up the long diagonal and if you
have these general exchanges
uh first of all knight e5 runs into
bishop cc it's even not possible but
even in case so if that would not be
possible just an exchange on e4
and followed by 96 would be also
perfectly in black's black's favor i
mean
there is nothing to to worry about so
hikaru has to make sure to
maintain some kind of
[Music]
some kind of pressure but how to do that
because black is about to move his
knight from e7 and then the
spawn and the pawn on e4 comes under
attack
exactly so rook on d1 to c1
kind of suggests itself after all if the
knight moves
uh white could crash down on the c7 pawn
peter
yeah rook dc one is an option
he's an option but you are still not
setting to take on c6 right
that is it that that that is true i i
i'm not
because uh there is a rook a1 response
yeah exactly so this gives me one extra
ply yeah another tempo to do something
that you might want to do
yeah yeah on the other hand it irritates
me that i can't move my knight because
this
pawn on c7 is hanging i would really
love to play something like knight d4
just to
just to get active can we that works
you you have some point of knight takes
b3 after rook takes c7
how does it how do the tactics work uh
peter rook takes c7
yes if i take on b3 i take on
b7 perhaps because b4 just happens to be
whoops
uh hanging an
unlucky happenstance uh unfortunately
yeah exactly it's just a very nice
illustration that yeah
all these lines have to be calculated
very precisely hikaru
nevertheless feels like he doesn't want
to give up the d
file and he played the move look ac one
right okay so with the move rook takes
d1 rook takes d1 again
black gets that extra tempo he may need
to solve his problems
um could
huh interesting could he solve his
problems with bishop d6
right exactly maybe just go back because
uh
bishop d6 would be very nicely met by
knight f5 if not for that this
evil pawn is hanging exactly like
capturing on e4 would even protect the
bishop on d6
perfect uh a perfect answer indeed for
knight f5 peter
yeah and okay if after bishop d6 yeah
bishop d6 on the board if you don't have
knight f5
black is able to move his knight away
from c6 to e7
going towards g6 covering the f5 square
at the same time
hinting at the pawn on e4 then
i feel like there is very little white
has in this position if he has anything
exactly my feelings precisely uh
i'm even thinking that knight c6 to b4
and in such positions i like to play the
breyer
i was never much of a martial gambit
player i don't know why
i wasn't attracted to the marshall
gambit for for some reason i was
attracted to the brayers
probably because i got too many soviet
bulletins of this
of the ussr absolute soviet
championships
and it seemed like everybody in those
days used to play
the classical rui and the breyer was
featured especially
in i want to say the games of boris
baskey so
maybe that was an influence and in this
particular position after the move
bishop d6 if i
see the move knight b4 or some kind of
knight move
coming i start to be attracted to the
black position we do have knight d2
on the board peter yeah knight d2 had to
be played
white is trying to get his knight to c4
also
makes ready white to play the
stabilizing move f2 f3
protecting the e4 pawn and if
f3 is played then already knight f5 will
be an issue
so black has to be careful
how how would you react you would still
go along with night before or would you
uh
well you you pointed out a very nice uh
or let's emphasize the nice point that
after the desirable in my view
uh knight before the move f2 f3
stabilizes the center and knight c4 both
knight c4 and knight f5
uh start to give me concern especially
as i can't play knight d7 knight c5
myself so hmm
um could we go back before the move
knight before peter
in this moment because the bishop on a4
makes a a little bit of a strange
impression right
if i go knight d7 and try to hunt
down the bishop well i better be careful
i could get
myself into trouble yeah knight c
f well no i think i'm getting myself
into trouble
uh peter knight c5 knight d6
and if i take on d6
this is uh very very bad news
uh for the world champion so don't let
don't
don't play like this magnus
okay so knight d2 on the board
knight knight a5 uh
that's not a very attractive move beater
but
maybe i have to simply stop
uh knight c4 yeah okay
knight a5 of course yeah it's it's not a
move we want to do because
the title e5 is really misplaced black
very much wants to go bishop c6 and if
he changes this bishop then
he should be fine but after look c1i
still keeps some pressure here
it does feel uh indeed like
you you are you are keeping pressure no
i
i don't disagree um and magnus went for
knight before i mean this is
this is the move that had to be played
and
in fact if white plays the move fc then
you have the option of going bishop c6
so
ah yes yes yes yes okay so
night night uh-huh
i also another reason why i wanted to
play this move night
b for peter is because after a move like
f3 if we put f3 on the board just for a
moment
there is knight c2 and potentially
knight
d4 if i can secure my knight on d4 i'm a
kind of a happier camper but
maybe i just don't have the time to do
that
well i mean knight c2 is a tempo so this
you get
right and after bishop f2 the question
you
probably want to jump immediately to d4
no
i don't know my bishop on b7 is making a
sorry impression
bishop a6 i
i i don't quite have the full
understanding of the position peter
yeah because maybe it's not easy to
understand yeah that might be one of the
reasons why
i had to think of it that way okay
knight f
oh i could also tickle bishop e2 bishop
d3
um well it's just a tough
game oh another no i like
i like these uh heavy strategic
uh maneuvering games though i must say
that i've always
found these maneuvering games and maybe
it was because i was so attracted to the
games of
karpov and tigran petrossian these
beautiful maneuvering games i've always
liked
this type of uh
play peter yeah it's it's very
interesting i mean
one can easily say that ah this is equal
this is end game this is boring nothing
is happening but there are
so many finesses in this position and
it's so easy to go wrong
and it's so easy to get out played by a
great player so
uh i am i perfectly understand why
magnus who is usually the big mice
of all these possessions was taking his
time before going night before because
it simply the position is still
so tricky and if you just make one
inaccuracy
your opponent might get the upper hand
exactly night before rooksy won
sidestepping any knights e2 trish
treachery and uh still angling for
knight f5 and knight c4 continuations
knight d3 on the board peter yeah
look c1 did stop knight c2 on the other
hand it allowed
knight d3 the black knight on dc feels
like
it uh doesn't attack anything but it
disturbs white's coordination and night
before played
where does this white look wheel hide
it's not easy to hide it
it's actually kind of funny because like
rook c3
knight a2 is a kind of a disturbing
little move it's like
where is that rook going i i'm pretty
sure the rook does
not want to end up on some uh silly
square like b2
either peter or b1 so
uh if hikaru wants to
continue the game he's going to have to
play rook c4 and he has
done it but doesn't this give the bishop
a6 as a tempo peter yeah it does give
the tempo and uh
hikaru is coming back to c1 i'm trying
to figure out
what his idea might be maybe his idea
was to
lure the bishop away from the b7 square
so that there is less pressure on e4
and those he will save a tempo on f3
and getting ready of jumping with his
knight to c4 or to f5
but uh it feels like black has
it's black to move so black should be
black should be fine
yeah and uh somehow a little
coordination has magically appeared in
black's
position because again after knight d3
now the
knight is perfectly well defended by the
bishop and it still asks the question
where do you want to put the rook peter
yeah yeah now magnus played the move
bishop d3
this is a d this is a nice this is a
nice move because he's hinting at knight
c2
attacking the bishop on e3
yes exactly wow
fascinating and while all of this
maneuvering is going on i just wanted to
give a really a big
uh big thank you to our audience thank
you so much for joining us
and sharing with us this magnus carlson
uh
chess tour finals benefiting kiva and
kiva is an organization
that chess 24 is supporting
in their micro loan activities uh for
those of you
who can see there's a green bar just
below
my name that's uh when tanya
and peter come on screen our goal is to
raise fifty thousand dollars uh
uh we're filling up the bar but
uh it's the potential is that today may
be
our very very last day of broadcast
as um hikaru with a three
sets to two lead could potentially win
this uh sixth set to decisively win the
match
and then we couldn't solicit you and say
please support our drive so anyone who
is enjoying all of the presentation the
tour itself
the games the broadcast uh go
to chester24
purchase a premium membership half will
go
to kiva you can also get
30 off of your membership uh
right now and in the very near future
uh the the price of a premium membership
will go up there are so many um
so much content that uh premium members
enjoy including that you can get a front
row seat
for banter blitz sessions
and play against the masters so join
with the masters
and support the program by the way big
shout out to pascal
charbonneau for his recent contribution
as well
great to be able to join the masters
uh peter uh not much has happened
uh but the rook on a8
which was pressuring the bishop on a4
but that bishop a4 wasn't moving
so in my view magnus made the right
decision
in grasping the d-file
yeah i think also that it's uh very nice
how
magnus reacts to it the lukon a8
actually does
nothing because this bishop on a4
connected with this uh very powerful
pawn on bc simply protecting this
bishop closed out that rook and uh
mangosam anticipates that there will be
more action coming along the
d file and he wants to make sure that he
is ready for it
on the other hand i also have to say
that hikaru did
very nicely by provoking this bishop to
d3
because after bishop d3 he had the
chance of
[Music]
going look c3 and all of a sudden this
knight on b4
and the bishop on dc construction is not
working that nicely together
now then knight c2 which was desired by
bishop d3
is not possible anymore because then the
bishop would be hanging
this also explained why magnus probably
wanted to get
support for for that bishop it looked
and he
did play the move knight c4 what is
happening is
if a pawn hanging or you just can't take
it because of some
ah there is this tactics yeah very nice
tactics if
black takes bishop takes c4 then white
can take knight e4
knight e4 knight takes d6 if you capture
with any ps then the pawn on c7 is
hanging
if you take c takes d6 then there is
this very nice
double attack with rook c4
uh peter i'm so delighted once more i
mean
can you imagine we've had 10 broadcasts
and in those 10 broadcasts
you've only hung a single minor piece
and today you've hung a rook which is
really really good it makes everybody
watching the broadcast
feel human okay so everybody watching
this broadcast
is feeling very very good you make you
made everybody happy peter
yeah very nice i told you right from the
beginning that i'm very very exhausted
myself
of course the line then correctly goes
like white first takes on d6
black takes on d6 you take on e4 and
then you go look c4 and
right but yeah magnus of course says
no no thank you very much i understand
what i have to do
and he did capture with the bishop on c4
i think this is a
utah class move because after bishop
takes c4
one could argue that this light square
bishop is such an
important piece from black side so very
difficult
psychologically to even consider giving
it up but on the other hand there are
new dynamics to the position and after
bishop c4
rook c4 knight d3 magnus feels that he
has nice harmony and he doesn't need the
light square bishops
his knight on f4 will be powerful enough
and will give him
enough counter play exactly this somehow
this knight maneuver to f4 makes a
pleasing impression
if black could just get in moves like g6
and king g7 as well the knight on g3
would be
facing no future bishop on a4
you normally talk about the two bishops
the bishop on a4
is nicely defended and and so on
but uh i like i like the way uh my
friend jan timon describes
uh the spanish is the spanish torture
and bobby fischer felt the same way but
for the spanish torture to really exist
the bishop has to be on the
b3 diagonal the joco piano diagonal
and here i don't feel that the bishop on
b3 is
that uh impressive peter
yeah okay of course white's bishop is
very very nice
let's uh it's pretty yeah i mean white
can go bishop c6
also white can also the group with
bishop b5 bishop c4
that's the diagonal that i think
uh white wants his bishop upon yeah but
on the other hand
simply there are no real targets in
black's position because this
seemingly passive bishop on d6 protects
the only weakness on c7
right and uh by expanding on the king
side with h5 king g7 and
eventually after h5 there is a
positional threat of going h4
so if white plays the move h for himself
which i would assume white should be
doing after h5
but uh that's also no currency of no
concern for black
right so this so-called bad bishop on d6
the passive bad bishop on d6
plays a very healthy role of protecting
the knight on f4 the pawn on e5 as well
as upon on c7
being protected itself
[Music]
reminding everybody of an absolute
masterpiece
that was played by magnus carlson
against elijah farrugia
in the vikanze tournament
um where where magnus on the black side
showed that these types of position
strangely enough
hold a lot of poison for white as well
it's not just play on one goal
as we often see in a spanish torture
peter
yeah of course white has to be careful
and it's a very very high quality
maneuvering game here
of course knight f1 had to be played if
white would
get the chance bringing the knight all
the way to c4
and also getting h for g3 and kicking
away the knight
it's the typical scenario white is
trying to achieve on the other hand
black now has time to maneuver his
pieces and
the move knight d7 is on the board
connected with
somewhere like a timely okay 96 says
not yet maybe it's possible because i'm
not sure that
after 96 you can really take this pawn
on h6 because black has some ideas
with g6 g5 but let's believe that
you still have to make the move king g7
first but anyway
what i wanted to loosely that once the
knight will be kicked for example after
let's make this move h for king g7 g3
knight e6 yeah you really got rid of
this powerful knight but
black is aiming towards the c5 d4
squares
and it seems like black has enough and
look at this knight d2
answered by bishop c5 ah by the way
that's a
just the timing of that move was ideal
because again
bishop c5 knight c5 rook c5 rook d2
and looky looky uh suddenly that knight
on
f4 is an absolute four
and the bishop on a4 is offside so uh
bishop c5 uh strategically speaking
um an ideal move uh
for black peter yeah it's
uh i mean it was a very nice tactic the
question is
now that what happens okay hikaru
clearly missed the move bishop c5 so
he had to lead it with the knight to f1
okay and
here is the big question does uh because
if you trade this bishop
it might look like it's great on the
other hand
then might get access to the c7 pawn and
the knight on e3 might be
very nicely placed so i'm not sure about
bishop takes e3
and i'm also not sure that magnus wants
to go back because he feels that
he can use this momentum and exactly 96
played
it's very much in the spirit very
nice again i just think we're seeing
really really just a high quality uh
maneuvering game it's not to everybody's
a taste everybody liked game one you
know attack attacks zack sack sack
but for for me i was always
i i loved these maneuvering games i i
just
i just to to me they were sparkling
they i found them very attractive this
move bishop c5 this moves knight e6
i i mean i'm just soaring uh with the
understanding that the players are
showing however i better
i better uh uh quiet my myself
uh peter i did not see knight g4
that comes with a strike against
h6 and e5 yeah
and this is the typical illustration
that uh
yeah one thing is understanding what is
happening and the other thing is to
to have very precise calculation the big
question is
did magnus miss it because he simply
felt like everything he does makes so
much sense and it
felt right or he had foreseen it and he
believes that
he has a nice way of dealing with this
problem
but what is this nice way
[Laughter]
you beat me to the punch that was the
question i had for you
wow did he i mean again the logic as you
say the logic of his moves really had a
beautiful
flow everything was very nice and then
suddenly at the end there's the scorpion
sting of knight g4
with this fork against h6 and e5 now
okay the only vulnerable pawn
is the b3 pawn so do we go
rook check and rook b1 or do we just go
rook d3
peter yeah well the problem is that
i also very much would love to give my
e5 pawn and get the b slip on in
as an exchange but the problem is that
there was
the chance that white first captures on
h6 and then comes back to g4
and i still might not be able to protect
my pawn on e5
and that exchange would already be
really
terrifying and magnus came up with the
move rookie 7 but
is this a clear pawn looks so
now of course don't the rook c3 that's a
landmine you don't want to step on that
square
anybody who's ever had any experience
with bullet chess
knows the pain of the night fork uh
92 peter so no no rook c3
but i i'm supposing rook b2
yeah rugby two but then black plays
c5 perfectly
now it now it starts to make sense once
more
either f5 and rook b7 or f6 and rook b7
on black's agenda by the way when the
rook gets to b7 it's not that we're just
going to
take the pawn on b3 there is the nasty
c5 c4
also as a contentious move um
yeah i like hikaru's move of course
because luke c5
had to be better you just cannot put
your look in such a passive position on
b2 yeah look c5 of course
f6 b4 played and black played the movie
c6
with with the idea of well threat is too
strong but certainly with the idea of
rook b7
um well again uh a well-played game but
i've i i've been thrown i've been thrown
off by the loss of the pawn
um uh peter
your take is it uh
is it enough uh activity by black
for the pawn that definitely doesn't
feel like enough
but the materials situation is
already such that black has excellent
drawing chances
he has the activity this knight on d4 of
course is very very powerful
on the other hand all white species are
also perfect
i wonder that maybe black's idea is to
go to k7 and
try to invade uh to the second rank
because then connected with some knight
e2 knight f4 ideas
uh you can combine pressuring the b4
pawn
and pressuring the g2 pawn absolutely
reed uh i like this idea of rook a7
might be off put by rook a5 but
you could first go rook b7 provoke rook
c4 and then you remove rook
a7 that combines very nicely because
then
uh there's no preventing the the black
rook from coming to the second
rank he's included the move g6
g5 as magnus because there was a
a potential threat of f4 peter
yeah that was f4 and also in general
something like h4 would
also be in white's favor just to get
that moving
okay usually this g5 move
with the another pawn on e5 weakens the
f5 square
in such situations but the very powerful
knight on d4 makes
very i mean does a very good job
covering that
that weakness yeah and magnus i think
absolutely rightly judge that
uh stopping h4 or f4 has
main priority now wow again the judgment
of both these players they're making
these
really really really difficult decisions
so quickly
and even saying that i do notice that
hikaru
is slipped behind magnus uh 140
on the clock to 222 again obviously
10 second bonus for each move completed
but you know i don't know uh peter i
i think i might just pull the parachute
and say okay
i see the rook coming to a2 i'm not
happy
i'm gonna go knight f5 or knight c2
and you know let's just make a draw all
right well
well done and he's done it
and we have seen yeah knight c2 the
knights were exchanged
black played the move look a4 very nice
because of course black
with this construction is ready to play
four against three so
white has to try to keep the b4 pawn
alive
there was no other way because if you
want to play luke c4 then
black plays the move c65 and exchanges
these pawns
using the pins so duke b2 had to be
played luke a3
and king f2 played by hikaru
right and i was about to say that that
that nice little tactic that you put
pointed out with c6 c5 that type of a
move
is such a key move for the defender
so that you force the trade of pawns a
very very very nice instructional moment
there peter
and ikaro is doing his best
to say look i've got the extra pawn
and in turn uh
magnus is doing his best to keep his
pieces active
but wait a minute that was a kind of a
surprise
turn for me i thought that magnus was
going to go
rook c3 uh instead of the move king h5
so that he would always be able to have
this rook c4
and and keep white's rook
passive he didn't do that peter
yeah he was kind of desirable but then
white goes kingy to king d2 and after
luxi for ghost king this league comes
luke d4 check can be met by king cc and
i'm starting with
luke d2 and also in the game i mean okay
magnus wanted to have counter play with
king h5 king h4
but this very nice timely move after
king h5 rook c2 was very important
because now if black goes
after the b for pawn then at the end of
the day
the f6 pawn is hanging right he had to
go passive with luke a6
and it meant white got extra time and
could immediately activate his king
so we saw kingy took edge for king this
the king jesus
king c4 happened and after luke a1 king
c5 it
feels like white has very good winning
chances but
uh this rook b1 defense was nice if
white wants to
win the c6 pawn then he might ah but
okay i have many options luxie for would
allow black to collect maybe too many
pawns
i i have to say uh uh
peter that i hate i absolutely hate what
magnus has done
and i really think that he's on the
precipice what about king d6
rook before king e6
and just trying to take uh the whole
king side structure off the board
that c6 pawn isn't going anywhere in my
view uh
what's happening in that case uh peter
yeah a very nice spot i mean with this
king d6 king e6
it looks very very scary very scary
okay hikaru did choose something else he
played the move rookie two
slightly surprising one check king d6
okay the idea is still there
marching with the king to e6 but why he
had to
put his look on e2 it's mystery
that's a mystery because i like the rook
at c2 it was eyeballing
the c6 pawn very nicely again time
trouble being
is is quickly becoming a factor of peter
uh if we just continue the line that we
kind of we
were looking at king e6 for just a
moment
rook before again i would have preferred
the rook on the c file
let's see what would have happened king
f6 i'm assuming king f4
rook back to c2 c5 aha
and if i bring my king now back to d5
peter
king uh e6 for example okay i just
wanted to
illustrate that yeah this is a very nice
pawn sacrifice because after luke takes
c5 black has this
intermediate check with v6 and after
the king has to move then black gets
active with luke
b2 and gets enough control play
collecting
white's weak pawns right so
but i mean what did he do he
he didn't he didn't play king e6 and he
didn't take he played luke cc but this
is like an empty move
check king e7 b2 is is magnus
escaping now
uh yeah
why not uh if
if white loses the f3 and the h3 pawn
it's
it's it's an easy draw oh my goodness
i think uh i think uh
a houdini like escaped by magnus i i
think he misjudged that ending with the
move
king h5 if we could go back to that
moment
peter when king h5 was on the board
because you mentioned
rook c3 king e2 but i wanted to continue
king h5 king d2
rook c4 king d3 rook d4
king c3 king yeah and i thought well
here at least this looks much more
challenging i want to put it like that
if the king gets to g3
the way it happened in the game i
really thought my goodness uh magnus was
playing with fire
and i thought he was lost peter frankly
that was yeah he did he did feel lost
but
also here i mean there is this uh pawn
and game which is
so strange i mean i've never seen this
phone because it feels like black is in
time to collect but
is black really time to collect right
right i'm going and you cannot get you
still cannot get a passer
but okay you can go king g3 right right
and that's okay you are this is fine
yeah this is the queen and pawn end game
uh
yeah wow peter tanya
that game tanya had is on the edge of
our seats what was happening at the end
did magnus slip that was indeed an
incredible yet again an incredible fight
and i think one of the ideas that i
found
uh a more human approach perhaps that
could have held on to the position
of course hikaru got a big chance but if
we just back up before king h5 and white
went king f2
and right about here one of the ways to
do it is actually to follow white's king
as well
with the black king and you just simply
go king f7
if you go king g3 you come back with the
king to g6 if you go king e2 you come
back to with the king to e6 and kind of
try and keep this position
because it's very hard for white to
activate the rook keeping the b4 pawn
protected as well
uh the way that magnus went i think he
had a big slip around here because
once white's king got activated it was
an extremely dangerous position
and keeping the rook passive on a6 gave
a white
a big uh a big opportunity i'm
because there was so much happening i
wasn't exactly able to check them
the exact moment where perhaps white had
a really
a big chance and
i think it was around here that we were
looking at
the end game uh peter and uh when
you pick up the pawn on f6 mm-hmm
when the black king comes to f4 king f6
king f4
and instead of rook c3 it probably made
a lot of sense to pick up like you were
saying just simply either pick
up the pawn on c5 or walk with the king
to e65 to pick up this pawn
but uh the move that hikaru played just
suddenly gave magnus a chance to come
back
and to get this extra tempo like you
pointed out so i think this was the
critical moment when he actually let go
of the big advantage
you don't have so much time in this
ripon ending to make moves like rook c3
which feel like a no move really so a
surprising choice and i wonder
if this was a mouse slip from hikaru and
was he actually intending to go rook c5
but was it a slip because rook c3 to me
makes absolutely no sense
i think uh tanya the the move that
on me to move that hikaru may be missed
with rook b6 because if you play rook c3
and black in turn makes a no move then
there's suddenly
g3 check and after king takes g3
king e5 or king g5 both and you've got
this threat of
f4 check and maybe you know in his mind
in under time trouble under the duress
of the clock
uh hikaru was only thinking
about what's good for him and if he
could get in g3
he was happy but the move rook b6 just
spoiled
everything that white was trying to
construct tanya
and that's an absolutely a very critical
point you want to play rook b2 but you
want to make sure that you push white's
king away from attacking your own pawns
and rook v6 check was that intermediate
move uh
no idea rook c3 was intended or was a
mouse that was did he miss rook p6 what
happened
because i also feel a move like rook c5
is extremely
just like a hand move that you make when
you're when you're
down on the clock not down on the clock
but playing on minutes
um a big miss really where hikaru
managed to create some chances
to equalize the game of course that
means that
magnus carlsen still leads the set one
and a half to half we've got
two more rapid games coming up
and with that let's also take a look
at what's been going on on twitter
because
just like us yes peter our audience
is just so thrilled at what what a final
this is
let's see what uh what you guys had to
say
and we had jer riding in with man game
one of this
game one of this set was simply
incredible broadcasters are saying that
apparently magnus has a non-chess
related back injury that is troubling
him
impressive to play that game while in
pain an absolute sensational game that
was magnus striking with the knight g7
blow and a complete knockout of a move
uh that took the point home some
inaccuracies followed but he was able to
do to do some damage control and
eventually
win and for those of you who are just
joining us and perhaps just joined in
game two as you perhaps saw on the
webcam
magnus carlsen can barely be seen on it
he he is suffering from a very
very severe back pain due to an injury
and
sometimes is looking for a comfortable
spot because it's absolutely
he's in anguish to even sit on his chair
uh
a very difficult situation really for
magnus playing this
win on demand set and also feeling
extreme extreme physical pain but the
world champion
is leading the set with his first game
victory we also had
we also had let's get the next one in we
had andrea riding in with magnus carlsen
can play an amazing attack against
hikaru
when he mostly needs it don't forget the
two players have just 15 minutes
great entertainment a thriller and an
exquisite lesson on modern chess
absolutely because modern chess or as we
know it is evolving it is becoming
faster shorter time controls it's moving
to online
and it's also interesting to see what
impact this will happen over the board
chess returns
but indeed these are the two best
players in the world
or at least the two who have made the
two best players of the magnus carlsen
chester 2020 as well we've seen
magnus has won three out of the four
events that he participated in
hikaru has been a finalist in two out of
three events that he participated in
undoubtedly the mvps of the door facing
off
in the finals in an epic rivalry
and we also had let's move on to the
next one
uh we had dread writing in with magnus
looks in physical pain in game two is he
okay or is hikaru torturing his soul
again
uh i i wouldn't be surprised if magnus
in fact did have some sleepless nights
and had a sleepless night especially
yesterday with the way seth went and
coming into today with being
with it being such a critical day for
the world champ and
as we were talking about is that he has
suffered from an injury today a little
before the game
and this has left him with some severe
back
pain it is being handled and it is being
managed
let's move on to the next one we had
we had hamad writing in and oh my god i
am so jealous of that photograph that i
see because those
are our hot drops from the legends of
chess the mugs that we had
the legends of chess are glued to chess
24 to see the final game of the magnus
carlsen chess store
and there you have it uh check out the
store this is an amazing
collection hamad and definitely have a
look at the store
and talking about the store of course
you can check out the mugs we've got
more excitement for our audience and for
all the chess fans
not only can you pick up these mugs you
can also book
and you can also see get a chance to
play against these legends
uh let's have that up because
you can reserve a spot against vishyanan
magnus carlson dingleroon and many more
of the chess legends
check out the store for for what's going
on and how you can do that
there are a lot of offers there and
talking about that
of course if you want to play against
the very best in the world you also want
to learn from the very best in the world
and for that we've got everything
covered and for that there is a great
deal going on
on the uh the play madness membership so
you there's a spec
a special prize on the on the play
magnus membership
and for the first time ever you get both
the apps the
the magnus trainer as well as the
tactics trainer
for and say 40 on it and these are two
amazing amazing apps to work on your
game on the go
the tactics trainer is a brilliant way
to get your
tactical skills on point and it's been
created by some of the best
puzzle experts of the world uh
definitely
definitely a must-have on any mobile
device
or your laptop so check that out and and
the magnus trainer
is also an extremely special way to
train your games in which there are
lessons and content
developed by the world champion himself
along with his team of grand masters
in an extremely engaging and interactive
format
the contents on the magnus trainer are
constantly updated
uh so yes if you can't have enough of
magnus carlsen's play during the tour
you can learn from him so
so check out on playmagnets.com there's
a great deal going on that
uh let's move on to what else we heard
from our audience
on twitter on social media bhavik
writing in weed i want to ask yasa with
great humbleness
and i do see asses with us so great
timing should just also have
awards oh my god i love this question
move of the year game of the year player
of the year
match of the year i think i would love
to get yas and peter's thoughts on on
all these uh
uh yes uh let's start with
the player of the year who would you
pick for 2020
i don't know who i would pick it would
probably come down to one of these two
players
depending on the outcome of this entire
match i just want to say there was at
one time a chess
oscars which i thought was really really
really great and i thought that
annually there ought to be a banquet
where there was
literally a chess oscars that celebrated
exactly these types of awards you know
uh the best player the best book the
best
streamer you know like just think of as
many awards as you can
and give them out because i think that
uh they're so deserving uh so to speak
so yes
to your tweet yes there should be
awards recognizing um
greatness i completely agree i would
love to see these awards as well
and uh peter what about you if you have
to say
for i feel like if you have to say the
match of the year that would be the
easiest to pick right now because we are
witnessing it right now we are in the
middle of it right now
and not at the middle but the very very
end of it right now because
ladies and gentlemen hikaru nakamura is
one set away
from clinching the magnus carlson chess
store uh
magnus carlsen in a win-on-demand
situation where
if he wants the match to go on he needs
to clinch
today's set what an epic door it has
been what an
absolutely sensational final it's been
and if
you all want to see more of this if you
want to be a part of
more such incredibly thrilling action
then please
do consider going premium there's a 30
off currently
uh and as we know that this final could
end today
or potentially tomorrow but it but it
could not potentially potentially could
end today or tomorrow
the court kiva finals expires uh expires
once the tour
ends so do consider going premium
because that would help
that would enable chess 24 and help all
of us
be able to put out this this uh amazing
content out there for you to put out
more such tournaments to put out more
such action out there for you a lot of
you have been asking
what is next the store is coming to an
end what's coming up
we're going to be keeping you updated on
that very soon
uh i'll be coming up with more
information on that on today's broadcast
but for now
uh definitely consider going premium
especially if you've enjoyed
everything that chess 24 has done in
response to the pandemic and to ensure
that we keep getting world-class chess
entertainment
all right peter yes one and a half
minutes to go
for game three magnus carlsen will be
playing again
with the white pieces what are we
expecting uh
in terms of the opening well
i was going to say that uh the english
a little bit got sidelined the london
got a little bit sidelined
peter i think it's signed that the world
champion just challenged directly d4
not necessarily the nimzo indian but the
queen's gambit declined
remember if he wins this game
and what a relief that would be for
magnus he would win the set and he could
go deal with his back pain
issues peter yeah it's it's a very tough
call
on once the end we have seen magnus
started with
one e4 and are we going to see
a berlin shutdown uh peter yeah this is
the big question because
yeah we are seeing bishop b5 and hikaru
is thinking is it hikaru really thinking
no we knight f6 played yeah and now the
big question is
what is uh magnus's uh strategy uh he
goes for the rookie one line
so he wants to be solid yeah and he goes
for cc this
in this means that magnus basically
wants to shut this game down
right a draw we've seen uh
this multiple times in this match
and again while this might not be the
most satisfying for
uh chess fans keep in mind what the
players want to do is simply win the
match end of story
so whatever they think will bring them
closer to victory
that's what they're going to do and
sometimes it means making a very very
short draw
as we've just witnessed and by the way i
was watching
um magnus on screen as he as he went to
get up from the seat
he went no that's not working i mean and
then he just did it a little bit
gingerly he is suffering
peter and he's probably thinking look i
want to get this
set over with asp
yeah perfectly understandable uh however
so far during this match this incredible
match between hikaru
and magnus whoever tried to play it safe
from the white side got punished yeah
that's
uh that's kind of when we
we wanted to discuss what's magnus's
strategy might be for this game
i had exactly this psychological aspect
in my mind that
will magnus really shut it down and
play a draw because after all it
backfired already in in previously but
on the other hand if he's in severe pain
then
every free minute which he gets uh is is
a very very big bonus
and then and in this case it's a very
logical reaction
so another question is
how hiccur will deal with the situation
he did have a
golden opportunity out of the blue by
the way in game two and if we will have
time maybe we can go back to this
second game to analyze little bit this
end game which which in my opinion was
very very i mean it was played
like super class for a very long time
and exactly when it felt like magnus
let me just get that position back you
remember we discussed about this
that hikaru missed the move knight d2
bishop c5
right clear yeah clear and magnus has
something like three minutes at this
moment
hikaru had like four four minutes and
maybe magnus fed like
wow i solved all my problems finally and
after night f1 the retreat
he just relaxed and played the move like
96 because it's such a pleasing move and
it makes perfect sense
looks like bishop takes d7 is kind of a
drawfur and if you are not taking on d7
you have nothing to play for
so magnus blitzed out 96 and all of a
sudden
dev to his horror he had to realize
after hika who played knight g4 that
there is a double attack on his pawns on
h6 and e5
and believe me once you felt like you
played a very nice game and you are in
the lead and all of a sudden you faced
with the situation that
you might lose this game it's it's a
terrible feeling
absolutely peter and it was remarkable
to me
the composure that magnus did exactly at
this moment because
nigey fork hits you like a cold shower
and you go oh
geez you know knight f6 check knight
takes e5 knight takes h6
and his composure and finding exactly
what he did find he found
rook e7 and knight d4
and f7 f6 and c7 c6
and suddenly with the moves rook b7
i mean it's he's not out of the woods
but he's getting
really really close to the coveted draw
and that was
that was impressive because it's very
easy to
lose your head when you've been hit with
an unexpected move yeah absolutely i
mean it was
it was a very nice defensive resource on
the other hand i believe
that exactly at the moment when he was
again relieved that who
i survived this adventure because it
feels like this
rook end game should be quite drawish if
not draw
then he he senses god
got simply trigged yeah because the move
king h5 is so natural and it shows so
much
such high class yeah that you are
immediately activating and you are
trying to enter with your king on the
other hand
after this very very strong move played
by hika look situ
highlighting that moving away with the
king from g6
from the f6 pawn forced black to
to go passive with luke a6 and after
kingi to king edge for king this the
king just
king c4 to be honest i felt like he
carries about two bonds back and
he gonna win this game exactly and for
me
um the move king h5 is fantastic
move it's a bad move but it's a
fantastic move why
because it goes to show what makes these
players
great magnus is a pawn down
he should be doing exactly what tanya
said go king f7
a shadow the white king make a draw
but the move king h5 is like i want to
make a draw on my terms
and by the way maybe the move king h5
gives me winning chances too
so sometimes these players
are maximalists uh peter and
you know like they they they go past the
boundaries of what they should
but we love them for it tanya
where set has set the stage for us
again another exciting set
another exciting set and now
it is hikaru who is in a must-win
situation going
into the last rapid game of today's set
uh hikaru is playing catch up with two
one
two for magnus a one for hikaru and
which means that if he wants to take it
into tiebreak
he's got to win uh the next
game with the white pieces and
uh of course uh the action might have
been slow
in this particular particular game of
this particular set but the action's
been immense on all our platforms uh yes
peter
we a big shout out to our audience on
youtube
on twitch on chess24 the chat there
you guys have been incredible and uh
thank you so much for all your support
and and hanging out with us watching
this amazing chess
entertainment show that chess 24 has put
together which
honestly has been nothing short of
spectacular and sensational chess
let's uh let's take a look at some of
the
tweets that we had
or okay we're gonna we're gonna wait up
with that
before before we go on to that of course
uh the big question
on every on on everyone's mind after
seeing
such incredible play is always how can
they improve their own chess what is it
that they can do there's every
i think all of us are so inspired by
seeing such uh
such a star cast and such a stellar show
of performance that we all want to know
what it is that we can do to actually
invest in our own education and what is
it that we can do to
to get strong at the game and of course
the chess action as always never never
stops
we've got it all covered for you from
the best course
courses from the best in the world
uh check out anisha's course on the
opening check out the magnus touch which
is an incredible course on the
on the end game and of course we have to
cover it up with what comes in the
middle
which is the middle game uh yes coming
out with his
winning strategies have a look
[Music]
[Music]
okay if this guy gets the big bucks like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course makes it great because
like
it's opening but with i've done so much
work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like basically correct also like fun i
mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
[Applause]
my name is sebastian milov
and i bring to you along with the world
champion
magnus carson the wonderful app tactics
forensic sold millions of unique
high quality and entertaining chess
puzzles that have all been
quality checked by strong grandmasters
like eunuch the camera and young gustav
become a member today and compete
for monthly prizes sponsored by
chessable
just24 magnus trainer
and of course king himself
magnus carlson we have made sure
that no matter how good you are at chess
you can
enjoy this app and get the challenge
of your life alireza varuja
alexander grishik sergey karjakin among
a lot of elite players they all love the
app
and i can assure you you will as well
download the app today and become a
chess
champion
[Music]
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help
underserved communities kiva does
incredible work providing micro loans to
help people around the world create
opportunity for themselves
and their communities when the pandemic
started kiva set up a global covit 19
response fund to help small businesses
get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support
thousands of people around the world
chess24 wants to help make that happen
during the tours final we will be
donating 50
of all proceeds from new premium
memberships to kiva
go premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your
choice in our shop let's show how chess
can play its part
[Music]
together
the dream is of course to get better at
chess but the dream is also to play
against some of the
best in the world and we've got that
covered for you because
check out chess24.com the store on the
website
you can book a spot for a symbol against
uh some of our legends who have
participated on the tour
uh you could book your spot against
vishwanathan
and against world champion magnus
carlson one number three dingler and and
many many others so definitely go to the
store and check out if you want to
challenge
uh challenge well the best of the best
in a game and uh also
the the big thing has been about chess
education and investing in your own game
so consider going premium to do that
if you're gonna play against the best in
the world you need to prepare strong for
it you need
to have all your all your opening
repertoire
and your middle game strategies all all
going for you and there's a 30 off on
premium by using the code
kiwa finals and of course 50 of all
memberships during this final
do go in for the kiva campaign once
again a big shout out
to all our audience who has contributed
in this great cause who contributed not
only
and invested not only in their chess
education but also towards making an
impact
in our community uh by supporting the
kivac campaign
and a big shout out and a big thank you
to the generosity
of the linderous abbey preservation
society
uh they were the hosts of the lindaurus
abbey rapid challenge the second event
of the magnus carlsen chess store and
they have
supported the campaign by contributing 3
000 euro worth of premium
memberships a big shout out to them
thank you so much for your support and
of course
no better time than to leave then now to
invest in your own chess education but
also leave an impact on the society on
the community
through chess also a big thank you to
international master sebastian
mihalo who is contributing 500 euro
worth of premium membership
to norwegian school children's school
children following our stream
on twitch and youtube thank you so much
sebastian
and of course norway's chess boom all
comes down to the world champion and
everything that he's done
and right now his task is cut we've got
action on the board
hikaru nakamura with the white pieces
and auntie berlin
uh yes peter call the action absolutely
thank you tanya and thank you
everyone for your support uh
peter we just saw hikaru playing the
very precise
castles he comes back and he plays c3
allowing g6
uh was this a slip i hate to say it but
i loved your
i love the castles and your explanation
for it
uh peter yeah i'm also completely
perplexed what is happening and
hikaru taking his time this is this is
not a good sign
yeah it feels like a slip previously we
had seen
castles bishop e7 c3
and we got a very intriguing loop
lopez i've been commentating too long
peter
a rui uh that almost allowed hikaru to
squeeze out a victory
when he really really needed it now we
have a repeat of what happened in a
previous set
that uh well magnus had no problems
as black yes in those games but
when magnus played that very specific g6
bishop g7
at that moment somehow hikaru run into
it
it felt like yeah he played the move d4
and
the move bishop g7 came like a cold
shower to him
and he didn't know how to react to this
bishop g7 and
didn't manage to to to pose any problems
in fact it was
exactly the same fourth game of the day
and he was in a
must-win situation by now i think he
also
managed to understand how to clean this
position from the white side
and he opted for castles
bishop g7 rookie one castle knight bd2
so
no direct action with d4 because
if white would play the move d4 here it
would exactly
transpose to that game which saw
this happen and from here we got this
bishop c6 bc
knight bd2 look e8 queen c2 c5
stuff which was so stunning and handled
beautifully by magnus i might say on the
black side
but yes please uh continue peter yeah
now he got to make sure that first he
develops
i mean there is no direct confrontation
in the center yet
so the both sides try to make
useful moves knight believe to look e8
knight f1
a6 bishop a4 everything very typical
black did get his bishop immediately to
g7
contrary to all those spanish is where
you first go bishop e7
you're gonna go 2k8 bishop f8 bishop g7
so one can argue that
aha so didn't magnus win couple of
tempest
yes he won couple of tempest to bring
the bishop to g7 but
since the position did not clarify it in
the center there are new aspects in the
position
and uh if i remember correctly there
were times when this position was
debated
quite heavily but it was something like
15 years ago
yeah and it has always been kind of my
feeling
that when black got the
fianchetto in in an accelerated way just
as you were saying peter
saving himself the tempo of bishop f8 to
e7
bishop back to f8 and then eventually
bishop g7 in other words
when this pawn is already on g6 then
having the knight on g3 is not that
uh attractive uh proposition now having
said that
hikaru's planted the knight on g3
he's probably preparing the typical
h3d4 um advance
and uh he says okay uh
we just got a position i may not
necessarily have a big advantage but
there's play and i need to win so i'm
keeping a lot of pieces on the board
peter
yes uh the point is that yeah white
really wants to play the move
hd and d4 on the other hand if y does
this then
i certainly have the feeling like black
won sometime yeah by bringing the bishop
to g7
immediately in basically just g6 bishop
g7 and magnus says
no you know what i got my bishop to g7
right
i want to be the first striking in the
center and he goes
d65 which again makes
a lot of sense in that game too we felt
that magnus was really really just
on the precipice of equality
maybe a little slip uh from
the middle game but uh certainly he has
nothing to complain about as far as
my eyes can see um now on the other hand
again
you know we kind of talk about that that
maybe the knight on c6 is just a smidge
misplaced offsides but it can't be
so serious peter yeah that's typically
the
only issue black is having in this
position because everything else is
very very harmonious black goes b5 and
there is this typical zaitsev idea going
bishop b7
and then re rebooting your knight to b8
and to d7 which i believe is very much
according to your
heart how you feel about this position
after you say that you love to play the
brayer
exactly exactly now we don't have
the zaitsev bishop on b7 instead magnus
has played a move
when you've got your pawn on h6 i kind
of always thought
that the bishop on e6 is very nice
another thing that i would just say
about this position
in particular if you just take the move
bishop e6 backwards for just a moment
one of the things i i love space i've
always been uh
uh in favor of having a lot of space
if though if there are those of you out
there in the audience
that think that the move d5 d4 is
attractive
well uh join the yasser sir on chess
club me
too uh i like these types of
space gathering moves when the bishop is
on e6
and when the pawn is on a4 sometimes the
move d4
can even come with good
uh strengths so um
by keeping the tension of the pawns on
d5 and e4
black always gives himself this option
as well peter the
the the option of playing d5 d4
yeah absolutely i mean it's also the
whole position
reminds me very much of of a duke or
piano in italian
when black basically got everything
possible
he he is the one who pushed this d5
and managed to get his bishop to to g7
right on the other hand exactly because
i know
couple of games and one of the games i
think kramnik versus anand
memorial something like this comes to my
mind where
all of a sudden kramnik proved that you
know what if you are having this bishop
on g7
and it seems that you have everything
under control on the king side i'm gonna
try to make
good use of the c5 square which is not
under control
and he did he did a masterpiece i mean
please check that game out it was
kramnik versus
ananda i believe it was a very very nice
play by
by kramnik all right we do have a couple
of moves bishop e6
and bishop d2 a modest move peter
yeah modest but okay white uh develops
very very much in the spirit of the
italian
also hinting somewhere at queen c1 just
okay it's not like winning i mean trying
to win upon of course black will play
in term of king h7 or tempo but somehow
also sidestepping any kind of exchanges
on the
d file and white's typical idea is
somehow to advance a4 and b4
and once you get those pawns then to
give the give the move to black and say
i know everything is perfect but
everything is so nicely put already
please make another move
right uh you kind of reach the zoo point
black as
at the zenith of his uh peace
configuration do something i'm not a big
big fan of the knight on f6 and i've
seen
um levon aronian uh uh if we're gonna
drop some names uh
you dropped vladimir kravnik i'll drop
lavona reigning
erroneous i've seen uh black at times
maneuver the knight on
f6 to d7 and somehow getting it over
there on the queen side not necessarily
because i wanted to protect
c5 but more like uh
maybe even mickey adams has played for
knight b6
takes a knight c4 peter yeah a very nice
reaction in general because white would
love to
get b4 a4 i mean or a4 b4
in but for this purpose knight d7 knight
b6 would be a great prophylactics
because then definitely black is ready
for all kinds of jumps on the
big square c4 and if we look at the
colleague on g3 then we understand that
yeah this knight has much more
perspective on
on the queen side however magnus
used a completely different approach he
placed the queen on d7 indicating that
the knight from f6 will not move
not move for quite some time so queen d7
a4 played rather quickly
and peter uh yeah i was about to say
if you're playing queen d7 it strikes me
that
uh magnus simply wants to centralize his
rooks
makes perfect sense to me and play the
move rook on a to d8 which is the follow
up he played
a queen d7 uh uh vacating the d8 square
and he's followed up with
rook d8 i like what you said a moment
ago the bishop d2 move was modest
but the move queen c1 could
sidestep uh a lot of
potential trades down the d file now
if you go queen c1 king h7 i'm still
kind of looking for an
active plan uh for white
what do you reckon um that could be
yeah the big question is do you really
have an active plan or do you need it
or you just should try to improve your
position yeah that's
a kind of a question in in a sense of
improving then
the already mentioned b2b4
is is kind of a possibility i also
wanted to
point out that yeah queen c1 is very
natural from
the right side i believe that even a
move like queen c8 would maybe be also
natural from the black side
simply that the queen on d7 doesn't
doesn't do that much
and with queen c8 you stop any kind of a
b a b rook a6
possibilities just in case and also you
give
the chance of later bringing the knight
via d7 to b6
ah queen c8 just dropping uh vacating
the
d6 square and as you say protecting the
asexual well
uh not queen c1 but a trade opening up
the a
file and now the move b4 by
white okay um
it did we're about to find out how
how much uh magnus wants to play for the
result of a draw
uh there's something to be said for rook
a8 peter and
maybe i like your move even better i i
i'm warming
to your suggestion of queen c8 just
covering the business square of a6
and maybe setting up for some kind of
tactics
down the d-file yeah that's
uh that's one of the main purpose of of
quincy it and there is another aspect
that
whenever white finally switches
ideas like e takes d5 with the id of
knight x d5 be answered by knighty for
jumping to c5
even for this idea the move queen c8 is
a great prophylactics because knight c5
will
never be a double attack on the queen
and the bishop
however magnus just wants to prove that
he has completely different
ideas in mind and he played the move d5
d4 this is
this is something of a surprise yeah he
wants to join
a membership in the yasuo cerewon chess
club
and space uh one of the
i i really respect these bishops on c2
very very very much so and i always
really admired how they often time
oscillate
back and forth between the b3 and c2
squares
uh inducing weaknesses it's somehow in a
very
strange way and the reason i like d4 so
much is i want to freeze that stupid
bishop
on c2 and say no from now on
the rest of the game your job is going
to be to defend d3
you're not going to have you're not
going to be an all-star performance
anymore so there's something about this
move at d4 that i like a lot now having
said that
uh queen c1 and maybe some
uh treacherous kind of
tactical uh trickery might occur
down the c file uh peter yeah i mean d5
d4 is
is a very double-edged move on one side
if it works out nicely then we say
wow bravo on the other hand if it if it
turns out to be
uh that you lose the game because of
this then people will
definitely say that why you had to play
fifa d4
just keep the tension man right anyway
didn't really
had any clear uh clear way to improve
the position
i i like your suggestion of playing
queen c1 here
eyeing the h6 pawn and also getting
ready for
any kind of d pawn exchange against the
c
pawn right and if black
uh captures on c3 bishop takes c3
uh it's very easy to see how you can
start to
target this pawn on e5 which you've just
highlighted um
kind of looks like some kind of a really
weird sicilian
if the bishop was on e2 you would say
yes it definitely has a lot of sicilian
motifs
the bishop is on c2 well again
uh just for those of you who are joining
us
late shame on you uh we're having a very
exciting set of games after three games
hikaru is behind by a point
to equalize the set and force a blitz
tiebreak he needs to win this game with
the white pieces
magnus makes any kind of results we're
going to have a day of reckoning
tomorrow judgment day
as that will be the seventh and final
deciding set should ikaru come back
bounce back and win the set he will
be the winner of the magnus carlson
chess tour um and peter we've got
a board full of pieces yeah absolutely
a lot to play for i believe one
strategical uh
aspect is that black will never
voluntarily take on c3 so
right move like quincy one will
definitely be answered with the move
king h7
and giving wide the move yeah quincy one
on the board
i'm expecting king h7 to also appear
pretty pretty fast but no magnus is
taking his time
magnus is taking his time one of the
things i also wanted to mention that
there is a question how you recapture
after c takes d4 and i believe that the
answer is
clearly capturing with the knight and
wow magnus takes dxc3
what is this it's the commentator's
curse peter
whenever we we we're we actually believe
that we're on solid ground
and you you don't want to voluntarily
capture on c3
just exactly then uh we get surprised
and by the way knight h7 quite the
surprise as well peter
no knight h7 is not a surprise i would
say that
once you take dtx cc it's clear that
magnus intention is to go knight h7 and
get a timely knight g5 in exchange the
knight from fc for for the knight on g5
and
get access to the d4 square uh having
said that the big question is
do you have the time to do that well we
just seen queen b2 let's do it
knight g5 let's follow the footsteps of
the world champion
uh peter yeah because i believe that the
only critical
movies can you capture on e5 but i'm not
sure you can
because otherwise if you move your
knight or you exchange on g5 then i
would say that
black is strategically perfect so i
should take but then you have some
tactics on the hd pony
well the for one and i think it is the
h3 pawn that he wants to smack down
there is something to be said for bishop
b3 and smacking on the d3 pawn but i
think
h3 is the cleaner capture
[Music]
yeah bishop takes hc okay there is also
the threat of bishop take g2 followed by
queen hd check so
why probably has to go queen f4
can i go queen f4 yes i think i can
and here there's some also some
treacherous
territory because maybe i can 96
can i play 96 uh oh
h6 is hanging i wanted to put my knight
on d4 with the tempo
i'm sorry i forgot about the h6 pawn
otherwise 96 knight d4
makes a kind of a nice um
look yeah makes a lot of sense but
i mean magnus says no no this is maybe
too much adventure for me
let me just stabilize with queen d6
after all your last move had been
queen c1 to b2 moving away your queen
from the diagonal and
i can play knight g5 next move without
any kind of complications
wow uh intuitively
queen b6 wasn't the first choice because
you see the move rook a6
grand masters hate just hate to allow
pins and put themselves into a pin
but i guess the move rook a6 can be met
by that move
uh peter the retreating move you've got
on the board bishop c8 so that
dissuaded hikaru and ikaru played
instead
92. but hang on what is hikaru doing so
after 92
knight g5 he moved away with the knight
to d2
yeah i understand him because knight
takes g5 eg5 is
definitely not an option in a must-win
situation
agreed black is imperfect control and
white has no chances of winning the game
so if he wants something out of the game
he has to try to keep as many pieces as
possible
on the other hand it's also a very risky
move exactly i wanted to say exactly the
same thing
uh it's nice when the player who needs
to win is keeping all the pieces on the
board and
and making the game the fight a lively
one
the problem is a lot of white pieces are
leaving the king side uh
peter yeah absolutely i mean
and magnus goes bishop ca that's the
other thing that this knight is
heading towards the e6 square and if the
knight gets to e6
then black gets perfect control of the
d4 square and one can see that this
whole idea starting with the whole
operation with d5 d4
was a really great success absolutely
because we've
spoken about maybe the knight being a
little bit
not not the most beautiful
on the c6 square but if
you black gets the opportunity to go
knight e6 and knight d4
quite the contrary uh the knight on c6
is a geniusly placed piece and it's
going to be an all-star
in the game ahead uh we've got well
nine minutes to seven minutes but i
would say
for a game that he has to draw magnus is
feeling
comfy peter yeah i also believe that now
he feels
comfortable okay one question is that
before black gets 96 in
can white consider something like a
shocker like f2f4
trying to spice things up thanks to the
thanks to the long diagonal okay i
believe that black should be ready for
it but
uh definitely f4 is a is an interesting
way to treat the position
it's a consideration but uh courch toy
would like to
take off his glasses rub his eyes
kind of look at me like yes sir
pawns don't move backwards it's a
consequence
uh peter 96 and
did the move f4 help or
hurt uh yeah and we're gonna we're gonna
see a trade bishop takes
e5 yeah yeah exactly that's that's the
problem because the you are simply
controlling the d4 square
too much now we see that this knight on
c6 knight on e6 are doing
perfect job and whenever i take on e5
you still have enough pieces to
to control the default because i need to
push dcd for otherwise my position is
falling apart
right so yes this is an answer that
unfortunately
you want to spice things up with f4 but
if it doesn't work it doesn't work then
you just can't do it
exactly that that is definitely a
boomerang
uh situation but now i mean
we've explained to our audience how how
difficult it is for um
ikaru to spice things up uh the
desirable breaks
f4 and d4 simply are not on
offer the bishop on c2
uh you mentioned vladimir kramnik and
putting the knight on c5
um peter uh i'm i'm kind of running out
of suggestions
uh and i i am feeling like i'm
leaving the king no i can't i i can't
hang the b4 pawn
you know i'm not liking this for hikaru
no not at all i mean black has very easy
game and
this we also see in the time management
yeah hikaru was so far playing rather
quickly but
the last couple of moves took time
and magnus is ahead on the clock it's
not obvious i mean magnus knows what's
his next move is going to be
and what white is supposed to be doing
if he can do anything at all
it's another question it's practically
not easy
yeah it's a bit of a mystery for sure
um oh boy uh okay
uh i got to do something h496
knight f3 uh peter
yeah i get your point uh that's that's
actually
probably the reason why hika is also
keeping his knight on d2 he doesn't want
to move it anywhere that he hopes to
to jump back with the knight to f3
but each force is quite a big cost
i would say i agree because it becomes
the g4 square
that's precisely right the other thing
that i was thinking
about with h4 peter is that i could go
h4 96 h5
and make some kind of pretensions i want
to win control over the
f 5 square uh not that i've
uh i believe it's it's possible instead
we saw a semi-move rook a8
uh peter yeah okay
in general i think it's a move that if
you don't know what to do
it makes a lot of sense to play a move
like look at
also giving black the chance to decide
what he gonna do if he moves back with
the knight to e6 then white can go
knight f3 but magnus said no no no
my knight on g5 is perfectly placed i
don't want to give you any kind of
knight fc counter play
let me try to attack your weakness on b4
and
magnus played the move bishop g7 to f8
and hikaru reacted with rook b1 there
was nothing else to protect the pawn
wow um you know again uh i can't help
but
i i've got this really weird feeling
like a lot of white
pieces are going queen side now
because of of this exact moment it's
probably a ridiculous idea but
bishop h3 just humor me for just a
moment peter bishop h3
rook d a queen d8 so the idea behind
queen d8 is i want to
earn the the diagonal to h4
yes precisely peter takes takes
the king has to go in queen h4 and i'm
on the doorstep
of uh a big splat on the king's side
well to my eyes it feels to me like
day after day you are getting stronger
and stronger
it's because of your it's your analysis
that is inspiring me peter well thank
you very much
but uh yeah this is i think also a very
nice illustration that people you have
to check out
what yasser has to say about the middle
game because i mean all these ideas
they are fascinating me so i believe it
will fascinate everyone
well uh again i i think it's
it's certainly worthwhile sometimes it's
a problem
when you have a good position you get
caught down a rabbit hole
because you think i'm doing really well
i put my knight on g5 and then you start
thinking yourself
how do i justify the knight being on g5
and you go oh i know i can sacrifice a
piece
i get two pawns i get a check i get an
attack yada yada
and then you start analyzing and then
somehow you convince yourself
it doesn't work and then you're upset
that you've cost yourself two minutes
on the clock when those two minutes uh
peter can be very valuable yeah that's
right but often it's also the case that
the more time you spend with the
variation you feel that it might be okay
it might be the direction but you simply
cannot
cannot finally judge it and time is
ticking down and then you say okay you
know what
i just played the normal natural way and
i don't go for the adventures but
yeah as you mentioned once you already
spend a lot of time with it
it's it's very tricky because if you
switch
and then your other idea or the other
way you are treating finding the
position backfires
then you will very much regret of not
using that chance
the other thing that i'm i'm thinking
that bishop h3
is definitely getting magnus's attention
is his attitude and his play throughout
not just this match but the entire tour
he has been taking uh the
the most aggressive way and he's gambled
as we saw in the semi-finals with
dingler in he's been willing to
sacrifice
his pieces maybe under even less
reasonable circumstance and like you
said he finally sat
he finally settled on uh
move b he just played bishop d7 peter
yeah he played the move bishop d7
and he kind of bleeds out 2k6
immediately
and another big question is that how
much time did magnus really
consider bishop takes hc and if he and
if he was considering bishop takes hd
and then changed his mind that
why should i do it let me just play
solid and then go for bishop d7
and get hit by look a6 which is quite an
unpleasant pin along the
sixth rank but magnus says no no i'm not
impressed i simply gonna eliminate this
rook from the sixth with luke 8
and by the way there's a very nice cheap
whoa
whoa whoa geez i was about to say there
was a cheapo
if you take that move back for just a
moment peter in case of bishop c8 i was
about to propose
bishop e5 that's right and in case of
queen e5 rook c6 thank you very much i
went upon happily but then i stopped
myself because
rook e5 is actually this could be
a combination that boomerangs against me
right because i
i've left the bishop on c2 hanging and
oops
that wasn't my intention when i played
bishop e5
yeah yeah that would have meant welcome
in the club yeah
yes exactly exactly i'm trying to stay
out of you don't want to join the club
my friend uh rex singfield uh
we were we were playing a very uh
celebrated
ultimate moves and gary kasparov had
gotten up from the board and said rex
your turn to play i i present you a
winning position
and rex promoted the pawn uh he pushed
the pawn to the
uh first rank pressed the clock
removed the pawn and put the queen on
the port
and was forfeited
[Laughter]
this is like the blunder of the century
and
unfortunately i joined the sinkfield
club as well i did exactly the same
thing
and i lost a blitz game that way um
we've seen a trade of rooks on the a
file peter
yeah we saw the trade of rooks and
well magnus just
goes on with his uh normal reaction i
mean just to stabilize the position
after all
white is the one who has to create
something that's why he has to win the
game
and he goes bishop b3 showing
showing his intentions that he wants to
to fight for the initiative this bishop
needed to be activated and the pawn on
this is
not hanging because white has luke d1
using the pin and hitting the bishop on
d7 at the end
very very nice cure to be sure it was
funny as you were pointing out rook d1
uh i was saying to myself i mean how
many times have i
you know just missed uh
i mean it's an obvious move but you you
just sometimes you get caught up with
your
own ideas and when magnus played the
move d4 his whole
purpose to my mind was to make sure that
bishop on c2 played
a silent role the move bishop b3 with
the intention of bishop d5
um that indicates that uh hikaru is
beginning to
enjoy his his position once more
peter yeah i also believe that he is
getting play
the big question is how much play it is
uh knight knight cd4 yeah now we are
seeing the
general exchanges on d4 a very typical
scenario and now the big question how do
you recapture because white wants to
make sure to get this unbalanced pawn
structure
that will give him additional chances on
the other hand black says that
i'm changing all these pieces i have the
a file and you have a weakness on b4
and you might not have enough time to
generate the typical counter play
against my king on the king side right
well i cannot tolerate the knight on d4
peter so
if i do capture it with the knight and
you recapture and i go bishop to d2
uh how would you evaluate the position
well i would avoid that it's more or
less eco but
i don't really see winning chances for
white
and in this uh aspect
bishop takes d4 ed4 f4 i was almost sure
that it's gonna be played it's
not the question if this is objectively
best or not
simply the situation requires this right
the match situation
is such that hikaru absolutely
positively has to win this game
otherwise it's set
over it's not match over it's just set
over
and we will be coming tomorrow for the
seventh and final set
f4 with the intention of e5
shutting down the bishop on g7 uh going
after the d4 pawn but
what is going on after
uh queenies oh the h4 pawn
was what magnus is after okay
suddenly the game has gotten ultra sharp
and hikaru and magnus well
they have a lot of time i want to say
yeah somehow this
this whole position got out of control
yeah we spoke about that
black having the knight on c6 knight on
e6 had a wonderful grip of the
possession
and it did feel like that however
all these sequence that we have seen
basically gave white a lot of chances as
well
i mean this powerful bishop on b3 is
very very nice he called
played the move rook c1 hinting at the
c7 pawn which is not just the pawn but
it would give access to the f7 pawn
exactly black black has very nice uh
play of course from uh
on the other hand that he has the two
bishops look d8 played
by the way c7 pawn is not hanging
because of queen e1 check
so something like lux c7 would be a big
blunder because of queenie one check
an immediate perpetual for black which
is all he needs to
to do uh to win the set
yeah and now hikaru played the move
queen cc stabilizing basically looking
at the even
but somehow all his pieces are a little
bit strange
true i i desperately wanted to get in
the move g6 g5 from magnus
to liberate the bishop i think sorry but
something like queen gc is that a move
that's a
an awesome looking move i i love that
move
uh queen
no queen takes okay maybe you have a
queen take c7 you have to but
queen c7 is is very very crazy and
magnus played the move queen g3
that looks incredibly powerful because
you're hitting
this gorgeous and very important pawn f4
but you're
also threatening the queen e3 check
picking up the knight
and by the way if the knight moves the
pawn on d3 is hanging
uh my first
instinct is white's position is
crumbling peter
yeah i have the same feeling that's why
i also interrupted you sorry for that
but
not at all no no no this was a good
interruption it
it simply fat like yeah this queen gc
because if this works then then it might
be game over in fact
right the only question i had that what
happens after queen takes c7
it feels like it should lose but i have
my threats with
uh with queen takes f7 okay give me the
piece queen e3 check
and queen takes dna for
i have to go to h1 yeah queen takes d4 i
take on f7
you go and then i enter with luke's c7
exactly now
[Music]
oops i have to rook d7 unfortunately
allows queen
g8 mate oh boy
so if i have to if i have to block with
the bishop
um i have a feeling
i i i'm just somehow i'm going to get
away
with a perpetual check somehow peter i
mean
you're going to win back the piece but
i'm going to go queen f2 and get a
perpetual check
yeah but that's not your main intention
after queen gc i believe and
magnus after queen takes e7 played the
calm little move look d7
like guys calm down i really like it
exciting
i know that it's exciting but i'm in the
driver's seat and i have things under
control
and that move uh perfectly exemplifies
that that
in fact is the case with the pawn on
f7 very nicely defended
with f4 hanging with the knight on d4
uh basically being lost
uh okay it's it's game over
uh exactly peter yeah exactly i mean
okay one it was a desperate try to
get somehow k18 but uh yeah
and already magnus has won the game he
can do design because his
complete position falls apart
wow uh i
impressive impressive impressive game uh
by
an impressive set by magnus tanya just
what he had to do the world champion
does it time after time he comes back
when he needs a win
absolutely yes this is the third time
that the world champion has
leveled the math score in the
finals and not just that i think today
it was incredibly challenging for him
not just over the board but it was clear
to all of us watching the broadcast just
how much agony he was
with his back injury i'm hoping that he
would join us
shortly uh of course we're gonna have
we're gonna have to make it really
really quick because it's clear that uh
uh he's going through a really really
bad situation with the back pain but yes
a big
big comeback and that means judgment day
is postponed to tomorrow wonderful
i am very very pleased because
they have thrilled us throughout tanya
and
an extra extra game
sign me up and a big win today i mean
look at that margin by 3-1 i think this
has been the most uh
convincing day for magnus not just score
wise but
never really getting in any trouble in
any of the games
in today's set yes absolutely really
controlled play wouldn't you
yes we do have we do have the world
champion joining us
so let's just uh
magnus can you hear us
congratulations magnus
[Music]
all right we're gonna we're gonna try
and fix that i'm not sure because we can
we can hear uh magnus but i think there
is some issue on his and
uh
[Music]
uh there we go
yes that means that we are going to be
having a day seven tomorrow which
uh that's it i mean uh it's a best of
seven
it all comes down this has been the long
haul in the finals
i'm still uh i'm gonna check if he can
uh if he can hear us
magnus are you here yeah sure yeah hey
congratulations
thank you magnus it was uh
it was very clear that today was a very
tough day not just on the board but
you were also going through a lot with
your back injury
uh what happened are you feeling better
um no so what happened is i was
generally feeling
great today and then like um
half an hour before the game i was just
going for a quick swim in the opening
oh sorry in the ocean i started running
and something
just um happened so
um but
there's a little less pain now than
there was
than there was before so i'm sure
i'm sure that winning this set
helps with with the pain a bit uh magnus
we're not gonna keep you for very long
because uh of course tomorrow is a big
day
just quickly briefly you could give us
your impressions about how the set went
today
um yeah i think in the first game um
in general it was okay um
i will just mention one moment which is
when he played queen b6
on i would say about move 30.
um yeah move 31.
so he started shaking his head after he
made this move
and i sort of i i guess i
i fell for the oldest trick in in the
book right
because i when he started shaking his
head i just assumed he missed rook d1
and it's game over um but of course
after
after work d6 i have to start all over
um
but yeah it turned out fine so i won't
complain
all right and uh of course knight g7 was
a
was a very strong blow did you see it
instantly when he played a6
yeah a6 was um was
very provocative um of course but
one of obviously one of the ideas of
bringing the rook to c5
is to is to
[Music]
take on seven and if i don't take then
my preceding
play makes little to no sense
all right and marcus big day tomorrow
just your thoughts on the final day of
this final
um it's obviously going to be
obviously going to be tough i feel like
every every day has been
has been difficult so far and i don't
expect this to be any different
i wish you a very speedy recovery with
the back injury and congratulations on
today's win
uh and we look forward to tomorrow just
quickly peter yes
anything from magnus well first of all
magnus a very big congratulations
i thought you played outstanding chess
today
thank you and uh as far as your back is
concerned i strongly recommend
find a masseuse get a good back rub and
i'm going to turn it over
to peter yeah congratulations magnus
yeah it was a fantastic day very nice
games uh
total control yeah there was this scary
moment on game two but
knowing your situation i don't want to
ask you any question just
hope that you will recover quickly and
yeah looking forward to this
seven set tomorrow thank you all right
magnus take care
and with that the world champion levels
the score and we get another
action filled final date tomorrow
the score is 3-3 i think i think yes
peter when this
final began with these two extremely
strong
players undoubtedly we knew that it was
going to be an epic fight
but the way i i think few of us could
have predicted
just the way the finals gone no question
about it tonya this has actually been
a ridiculous final if you got a
hollywood scriptwriter and said
okay sit down and tell us
what would keep the fans on the edge of
their seat
they would come up with this precise
script and the producer would say
can't use it it's ridiculous it's not
happening this has been unimaginable
and for magnus time after time each time
he's been behind in the march
somehow he digs down deep
and he returns the set and tanya this
has been an amazing match to call it
it's it's fantastic
it's it's epic it's ridiculous
absolutely and peter what about your
thoughts on how
today uh went yeah well i have the same
impression as
as you said that okay it's a fantastic
match and
right from beginning of course probably
nobody could have expected that it's
gonna be
so close and so tough but when hikaru
started
with winning the very first set and we
saw him playing more and more confident
somehow it was looming in the air that
there might be some surprise
and to be honest i'm not surprised at
all that we are
gonna see this game seven because this
match really deserves game
i mean set seven and i think all the
world is
waiting for this day tomorrow to come
tomorrow indeed is uh judgement day a
lot of
our audience uh watching us on youtube
and twitch big shout out to all of you
for
uh being a part of this show and
engaging with us on twitter
as well you have been comparing magnus's
performance today
to michael jordan's performance in the
1990s
finals against against the match against
utah jazz
and uh it was when he it was the flu
game the famous
uh flu game and i think where literally
michael jordan willed himself to perform
for his team
uh just exceptionally unwell and i think
one of the legendary moments the things
that makes legends is that when the
going gets tough
you know what it is the rest of it the
stuff gets going and that's exactly what
magnus carlsen did today
hats off to the world champion for for
literally willing himself
into leveling today's mat today's set
and fixing up for the final day
of uh the tour final it's not been easy
for magnus carlsen this entire finals
kudos to hikaru nakamura
for just the epic fight and the battle
that it's been he's taken lead
thrice in the entire match he's been the
one who magnus has been playing
catch up to and finally it all comes
down to a
big big day tomorrow let's quickly take
a look at
what was going on on twitter we had
we had let me see if i can get that up
we had silicon writing in i wish
lecco comes out of retirement and plays
the next world blitz championship like
how kramnik did
the last year lego's tactical knowledge
now is no lesser than the current top
players
felt that while he was commentating on
the second game i have felt that
throughout the event peter it's uh yeah
speed of both of you really i mean the
insights that you've given us
how you've called on the action i think
i think all of us want to want to see
you back
on the board peter any chance of that
happening
well thank you very much
it's it's been of course a thrilling uh
thrilling magnus tour
and it gave me so much pleasure i also
had the chance of
playing in the legend tournament and to
be honest i felt like
it it was very very nice because the
feeling that i can still compete against
the very best players
this this motivates me and gives me a
lot of lot of strength on the other hand
i very much wants to see
yaser in the u.s championship because i
feel like yasser is in top shape
and i mean i was already hardly able to
control him in the last couple of days
so
yasir just get the wild card i want to
see you there and
beat everyone well i can tell you uh
i think it's a young ladies game i think
it's a young man's game and i'm happy
to make room for what i see
as some phenomenal phenomenal junior
talents i mean
tanya the the kids from
india you should scare the bejesus out
of anybody
the kids from america are phenomenal
i think that the future of chess is
assured
by the generations of talents that we're
seeing today
and i'm happy to give the stage to them
i think it's we we we're going to see
you know wonderful wonderful things in
the years ahead
uh maybe maybe maybe just saying just
saying
a seniors championship you know
i i like the legends of chess type of
thing
but no i mean i i see the competition
and how tough it is
no way not getting me back there i'll
stay out of the arena
yes as long as we've got you
commentating and calling on the action
uh i think uh we'll take that uh
that we'll take whatever we can get uh
but it's been uh
it's been such an honor to be a part of
this entire tour
and to be able to uh to hear the two
two legends uh yasser sarawan and peter
leko commentates so
absolutely and then we also had them
i'm sorry i'm definitely gonna get this
name wrong but
melter writing in magnus carson leading
against hikaru besides having a lot of
back pain while losing three sets in
normal condition crazy games crazy
blunders
so far hikaru seriously challenged him
the past couple of days
i think uh i think you're spot on with
the with the challenge and i think
tomorrow is going to be
absolutely major for both these players
so much at stake 160 000
for the winner there's uh the the
runner-up goes up with 80 000 but it's
not just that
this final has been such a process such
a journey for these two players that it
just
and they're so close to it i mean hikaru
is definitely on his a-game
it just completely informed finding
absolutely incredible resources
on the board playing world-class chess
at par with the world champion
magnus carlsen for the first time in the
entire tour
is is not he's not really being able to
to do much on the board uh today he had
a good day he had a good day at office
he was able to bounce back and
absolutely
it was incredible to watch him watch him
on camera i mean this is what champions
are made of i think it was uh
uh while during the broadcast
we were seeing just how how much in pain
and agony and
anguish he was but just incredible and
hats off to the world champion for being
such a legend continuing playing
as well at just non-stop play and i i
know that
for a fact that not once did he propose
to to
stop for a couple of minutes or to get a
little bit of rest as yes you were
pointing out
uh it's not there in the regulations and
it was not asked by the world champion
it was just uh
amazing to see and this is exactly what
champions are made of hikaru nakamura
is also what champions are made of so
we're gonna have two champions tomorrow
fighting it out for big bucks and
whoever wins
truly deserves it it's just hard to pick
a winner
and uh with that we are gonna call it a
rap but of course a big reminder to all
of you that the chess
must go on because it's just a game that
all of us have fallen in love with and
that's
big thanks to this entire tour for that
for getting us addicted to this sport
and uh for all the all the joy that it's
given us during a very difficult and a
challenging time
you can contribute and make sure that
events like these continue
by considering going premium and
supporting everything that chess 24 does
there's a 30
off and also that would ensure that we
keep
bringing you all this insane action
uh at uh this time as well as in the
future there's also been some big news
about
the first big over-the-board tournament
being announced by
norway chess and uh i am super excited
to hear that the lineup
is insane we're going to be talking more
about that tomorrow but
lots to look forward to chess 24 is
coming up with some amazing innovative
events as well
keep your eyes out on that there is a
big 30 off right now which i know
expires once the tour finishes so
consider doing that and of course
to prepare for all the chess action that
you are going to be a part of
definitely check out all the great video
courses available online on
chessable.com there are some great deals
on that
you got the openings covered you've got
the middle game covered we've got end
games covered
to make sure that you're up to the task
of playing some good chess
yourself it's good night from all of us
we will see you tomorrow
thank you for joining us
no but nobody likes the french i also
didn't like the french but
like the course makes it great because
like
it's opening but with i've done so much
work
to make it actually kind of first of all
correct
like basically correct also like fun i
mean
i'm making like i basically recreate
like i take this crappy french and make
something great out of it
you